bonjour à tous La séance est
ouverte madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers
collègues ces derniers jours deux
tempêtes ont balayé la France
métropolitaine de la Bretagne à la Corse
occasionnant d'importants dégâts causant
la mort d'au moins trois personnes
d'autres pays sont touché par ce
phénomène climatique exceptionnel qui
met durement à l'épreuve notre capacité
de résilience collective
des milliers de foyers ont été privés
d'électricité 90000 connaissent encore
des coupures d'électricité de nombreux
voyageurs ont été bloqués plusieurs
heures durant dans des trains à l'arrêt
le Pas de Calais est toujours en alerte
rouge et six départements demeurent en
vigilance orange le nord les deux sèves
la Charente la Charente Maritime la
Dordogne et la Gironde dans ces
départements j'en appelle à la vigilance
de tous car des crus exceptionnelles
sont en cours malgré les risques les
élus les collectivités territoriales les
services de secours nos forces de
l'ordre et tous les autres services de
l'État se sont mobilisés et continue de
l'être pour établir au plus vite des
conditions de vie normales et secourir
les personnes pas moins de 5000 agents
de la SNCF sont intervenus pour dégager
plus de 2000 arbres tombés sur les voies
et ont procédé à quelques 500
interventions pour réparer les catéir je
voudrais que nous saluions ensemble le
travail de ces équipes qui ont pu
rapidement remettre les lignes en
service ou mettre en place des lignes de
bus de
substitution au nom
de au nom de la représentation nationale
je veux rendre hommage à l'ensemble des
pompiers secouristes policiers gendarmes
agents public et bénévoles qui n'ont pas
ménagé leurs efforts au service de leur
concitoyens il mérite notre estime et
notre
reconnaissance parmi les victimes il y a
Frédéric dépa agent de nedis il est
décédé en service électrocuté il était
venu du gerse pour secourir les abonnés
du
Finistère en sa mémoire et pour son
dévouement madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous demande de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence
je vous remercie
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Monsieur Marcelin nado
pour le groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Madame Catherine
Colona ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangère madame la ministre
dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien les pays occidentaux
en appelant à la seule trêve humanitaire
tente d'apparaître comme les garants du
droit international mais abdict devant
la loi du plus fort l'humanité ce n'est
pas cela nous devons au contraire
affirmer l'absolue nécessité d'un cesser
le feu immédiat et le rappel de la
solution des deux états préconisés par
l'ONU nous devons ensuite éviter que ce
conflit soit une guerre de civilisation
dans laquelle une démocratie se
défendrait contre des barbares comme au
bon vieux temps des guerres coloniales
comme autant des massacres de Madagascar
de CTIF le conflit aujourd'hui n'est-il
pas le résultat de deux logiques
extrêmes qui ont empêché la solution de
deux états
démocratiques les Conventions de Genève
doivent être respectées au moment où
cette convention était signée celle de
1864 les guerres coloniales faisaient
rage il fallait civiliser la guerre
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus possible nous
devons apprendre de l'histoire nous
devons savoir tirer les leçons de
l'histoire il n'y a plus de barbare les
crimes de guerre ne peuvent se just ne
peuvent justifier l'excès de cruauté une
violence ne peut justifier par ne peut
se justifier par la nécessité de la
guerre l'horreur ne peut en aucun cas
justifier l'horreur de l'Ukraine à Gaza
la France doit être claire face au
droits des peuples à disposer d'eux-même
face au au non respect du droit
humanitaire et au crimes de guerre or
dans les deux cas le droit international
est pareillement violé aujourd'hui nous
attendons dans ce conflit que la France
soit porteuse des valeurs démocratiques
du respect de tout le peuple et des
exigences du droit international et cela
passe par cesser le feu
immédi merci beaucoup parole est à
Madame Laurence B secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'Europe s'il vous plaît merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
nado tout d'abord je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères Catherine
Colona qui est au Japon pour une réunion
du
G7 il y a un mois jour pour jour la
barbarie terroriste s'est abatue sur
elle a fait 1400 morts dont 40 français
de nos compatriotes sont encore portés
disparu dont plusieurs mineurs et je
pense comme nous tous d'abord à ces
Français meurtris par le terrorisme du
Hamas
face
merci face au Hamas nous avons une ligne
très claire Israël doit protéger sa
population et les Palestiniens ne
doivent pas être sacrifiés à la lutte
contre ce groupe
terroriste face à la catastrophe
humanitaire à Gaza nous disons deux
choses d'abord premièrement qu'une trêve
humanitaire est absolument nécessaire
nous y appelons avec force et un
consensus soutenu par la France été
trouvé sur ce point au sein de la
communauté internationale qui a entériné
la résolution présentée le 26 octobre
par la Jordanie à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies
deuxièmement je crois monsieur le député
que vous en serez d'accord il nous faut
de reconnaître que l'aide n'est pas à la
hauteur de la situation nous devons
collectivement faire davantage et vite
et c'est pourquoi la France organise le
9 novembre à Paris une conférence
humanitaire internationale pour la
population civile de Gaza nous sommes
pratiques et en action sur le terrain
puisqu'il s'agira d'apporter une réponse
aux besoins et à la protection de la
population civile palestinienne à Gaza
avec tris
objectif madame la ministre merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane vir pour le groupe les
républicains merci merci beaucoup madame
la présid ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie alors
que le projet de loi visant au plein
emploi a fait l'objet d'une CMP
conclusive je m'interroge monsieur le
ministre sur la capacité de notre
économie à y contribuer le tableau
brillant fait de la situation économique
de la France me paraît contredit par les
chiffres les difficultés s'accumulent
pour nos entreprises pour nos
commerçants pour nos artisans des coûts
d'approvisionnement toujours plus chers
et une inflation qui les frappe une
énergie toujours très élevée
des taux d'intérêt à haut niveau des
délais de paiement à rallonge je
pourrais continuer l'horizon est sombre
à ce jour la France ne crée plus
d'emplois elle en perd même 17000
emplois supprimés dans le secteur privé
ces derniers mois le chômage repart à la
hausse la productivité de notre pays a
diminué les dépôts de bilan explosent
plus de 10000 procédures collectives en
3 mois et les faillite menace en cascade
monsieur le ministre partout sur le
territoire et dans tous les secteurs
activité des entreprises sont sous
tension sont sur le fil du rasoir dans
certaines elles sont dans l'incapacité
de de rembourser leur PGE dans les temps
le prêt garanti par l'État qui était
nécessaire pendant la crise sanitaire
est en train de devenir un fardeau pour
beaucoup d'entreprises les petits
patrons n'en peuvent plus et s'ils
parviennent pour l'instant à le
rembourser c'est au prix des
renoncements à investir ou à embaucher
alors ma question est simple que
comptez-vous faire quelle solution
avez-vous pour enrayer ces cessations de
paiement et ses faillites pour soulager
les entreprises face à leur échéance de
remboursement de PGE et éviter que le
chômage ne continue de repartir à la
hausse je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre déléguée chargée des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du
[Applaudissements]
tourisme merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député
viri nous n'ignorons pas l'inquiétude
qui monte notamment chez les petits
patrons les artisons et les petites
entreprises notamment relativement au
remboursement de leur prêt garanti par
l'État et vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Député viri ce prêt a été très important
pour les aider aussi à passer la crise
du covid à date les chiffres de la
Banque de France que vous connaissez
nous indique que le taux de défaut
anticipé des PGE reste très faible et je
partage avec la représentation nationale
la dernière estimation donne un chiffre
en légère baisse passant de 4,6 à 4,4 %
sur la durée de vie du dispositif fin
juillet 2023 seul 1,81 % des PGE ont
nécessité l'activation de la garantie de
l'État mais vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Député vir et nous le savons je suis
bien consciente qu'il faut se méfier des
moyennes qui cachent en réalité des
situations bien différentes parfois
disparates entre les entreprises ce qui
est assez normal puisque je rappelle que
plus de 800000 PGE ont été délivrés
représentant un montant de plus de 140
milliards d'euros lors de la crise covid
je pense important de rappeler certains
points vous l'avez dit les entrepreneurs
sont responsables et pour la plupart
parviennent à rembourser leur PGE mais
parfois au prix de moins
d'investissement ou au prix parfois de
leur marge qui diminue aussi la réalité
c'est que quand on a un PG PGE de moins
de 50000 € je le redis on peut
rééchelonner la durée de son PGE sans
aucune condition et sans aucune
conséquence surtout sur 10 ans au lieu
au lieu de 6 ans devant le médiateur du
crédit au-delà de 50000 € je le redit on
peut renégocier aussi avec son tribunal
de commerce en se rapprochant du
conseiller en charge de l'accompagnement
des entreprises en difficulté à la
préfecture l'ensemble de ces conseillers
sont mobilisés 20000 entrepreneurs ont
été accompagnés et le moment est un peu
compliqué mais les entrepreneurs
tiennent le coup la plupart d'entre eux
cherchent des compétences à embaucher
vous parlez de moin 7000 emplois
rappelonsnous que c'est 138000 emplois
créés sur l'année qui vient de s'écouler
et donc nous sommes là pour les
accompagner je vous Remer merci madame
la ministre monsieur le
député madame la ministre je reçois
votre votre réponse il n demeure pas moi
que en réalité partout dans les
territoire la trésorerie des entreprises
et notamment des PME et des TPE plongent
actuellement et les signes d'inquiétude
sont légion et coûte que coûte il faudra
une action une réponse du gouvernement
je vous
remercie la parole est à Mame madame
mélaniein pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre si dans le
Pas de calis des milliers d'habitants
sont sinistrés sous les EAU les
Finistériens ont été durement éprouvé
par la tempête Karon son exceptionnelle
violence les dégâts considérables subis
ont fait remonter le souvenir
dévastateur de l'ouragan de 87 TPE PME
et surtout agriculteur payent un lourd
le président de la République conscient
de la gravité de la situation s'est
rendu dans ma circonscription auprès des
producteurs de fraises de plugastel pour
porter un engagement fort le chef de
l'État a promis de décréter l'état de
catastrophe naturelle partout où on
pourra le faire pouvez-vous nous
expliquer comment la tempête 40
peut-être classée en catastrophe
naturelle car la loi exclu de fait les
tempêtes du régime des catastrophes et
des calamités agricoles pour tout vous
dire
ce que le président a annoncé n'est pas
clair un grand nombre d'exploitants sont
très inquiets attendent des précisions
concrèt concernant les promesses
présidentielles pour ne pas compromettre
leur activité la survie de leur
exploitation les agriculteurs ont besoin
d'un accompagnement d'urgence pour la
casse pour les pertes qui sera concerné
par l'état de catastrophe sous quelles
conditions quel délai madame la Première
ministre les Finistériens préoccupés
attendent de votre part une réponse
claire et précise
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier verrand porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
madame la députée Thomas merci pour
votre question madame la députée vous
l'avez souligné cette tempête qui a
balayé le nord-ouest de la France n'a
rien d'ordinaire et d'ailleurs il y a eu
trois fois plus de foyers privés
d'électricité par exemple dans le
Finistère que lors de la le précédent la
précédente tempête de 1999 ça a été dit
par madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons à déplorer trois
morts et notamment un agent d'enedis qui
était venu en renfort depuis la région
d'occcitanie plus de 40 blessés
également dont parmi eux des pompiers
parmi les milliers de pompiers qui ont
été déployés sur tout le territoire
concerné plus de 11000 interventions ont
été réalisées de la même manière des
milliers d'interventions ont été
réalisées par les salariés d'énedis dont
3000 d'entre eux étaient prépositionnés
madame la députée avant de vous répondre
peut-être d'abord saluer le dispositif
de d'alerte qui a pu être mis en place
pour la première fois dans notre pays
dispositif fr alerte et qui a permis
quand même à 98 % de la population
concernée d'être non seulement alerté
sur les risques liés à la tempête mais
sur les gestes à réaliser pour pouvoir
se protéger et nous pouvons dire que
sans ce dispositif d'alerte le bilan
humain aurait sans doute été beaucoup
plus important vous soullignez madame la
députée dans votre question le nombre de
pertes qu'il y a pour les exploitations
agricoes pour les communes concernées
pour les foyers pour les maisons qui ont
été détruites les installations
routières je vous redis ce qu'a dit le
président de la République parce que
c'est ce qui va se passer toutes les
communes qui relèvent de l'état de
catastrophes naturelle seront reconnu
comme telles il y aura une réunion du
comité catastrophe naturelle qui va se
tenir ce 14 novembre et dans les jours
qui suivront un décret sera pris de la
même manière les engagements qui ont été
annoncés par le chef de l'État mais
également par la première ministre qui
s'était déplacé dans le Calvados ce même
jour et bien s'agissant des agriculteurs
ils recevront tout le soutien évidemment
des assureurs qui sont mobilisés mais
également de l'État partout sera
nécessaire croyez en la détermination de
l'état pas que sur le coup de la tempête
mais aussi dans la durée c'est ce que
nous leur devons je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre madame la
députée monsieur le ministre quand on a
tout perdu rien ne serait pire qu'un
espoir déçu il y a urgence indemniser
l'ensemble des secteurs agricoles
touchés séristes maréchés pépiniéristes
éleveurs l'agroalimentaire les
conchiliculteurs les pisculteur en dépit
des annonces présidentielles tous ces
acteurs se retrouvent seuls face à
l'assureur
enfin je voulais le dire n'oublions pas
les foyers qui restent encore
aujourd'hui sans électricité saluer
l'esprit de solidarité qui a surgi au
cœur de la crise maire agent public en
première ligne dans cette situation
d'urgence qui nous a coupé du reste du
monde les professionnels et bien sûr
leur sous-traitant sur le pont au péril
de leur vie madame la Présidente vous
avez évoqué laagouredis décédé il est un
héros du service public et dans notre
mémoire
collective merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Erwan balanan
pour le groupe démocrate merci merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre dans le dans le Finistère nous
en avons connu des tempêtes pour tous
celle qui vient de dévaster la pointe de
la Bretagne et le nord-ouest de la
France avait un nom siaran pour nous
habitants de la 8e circonscription du
Finistère il restera un autre prénom un
autre nom et surtout un visage associé à
cette tempête celui de frééri DESP agent
d'énédis décédé en travaillant à
rétablir l'électricité pour des milliers
de Bretons il avait 46 ans et 3
enfants originaire de h il venait dans
le de la force d'intervention rapide
avec de nombreux agents enedis pour
réparer le réseau électrique
complètement dévasté je souhaite et vous
l'avez fait aussi en mon nom et au nom
des habitants de ma circonscription lui
rendre hommage ainsi qu'à sa famille son
son sens du devoir pardon nous honore je
veux aussi remercier et surtout
féliciter le préfet du finisterère et
ses services tous les agents publics et
tous les élus des collectivités locales
les forces de l'ordre les pompiers et la
sécurité civile ainsi que les citoyens
qui ont fait preuve d'une solidarité
incroyable alors si cette crise a été
bien anticipée et bien gérée elle nous
interroge nous savons le dérèglement
climatique ne va ne va qu'accienter ces
catastrophes nous sommes devenu
dépendant aux télécommunications et la
coupure totale de tous les réseaux
mobiles et filè a été particulièrement
mal vécu par tous habitants élus et
forces de l'ordre il est primordi
primordiale pardon d'en tirer les son
pour améliorer notre anticipation et
protéger la population dans la
continuité du déplacement de Jean-Noël
barauier que je remercie pour son
soutien je souhaite m'adresser à madame
la Première ministre comment l'État
compte-il améliorer son plan de gestion
de crise et d'adaptation pour améliorer
la résilience des réseaux et leur
capacité à rester
opérationnelle merci beaucoup mon chers
collègues la parole est à madame la
Première ministre merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Erwan
balanan je voudrais à mon tour exprimer
toute ma solidarité et mon soutien aux
victimes à leur famille et à leurs
proches et j'ai également une pensée
pour tous ceux de nos concitoyens dont
les biens ont subi des dégâts
considérable alors vous l'avez dit le
bilan est lourd mais il aurait pu être
dramatique et si nous avons pu faire
face à ces épisodes climatiques
exceptionnels c'est grâce au dispositif
d'alerte au dispositifs de prévention et
également à la responsabilité de nos
concitoyens c'est grâce également à la
mobilisation exceptionnelle de nos
sapeurs pompiers des équipes de secours
des équipes des collectivités qui sont
intervenu y compris au plus fort de la
tempête pour venir en aide à nos
concitoyens et je veux à nouveau
vraiment le leur rendre hommage alors
vous l'avez dit ces tempêtees ces
dérèglements climatiques on sait
qu'elles vont être amené à se
reproduire si nos opérateurs de réseau
ont été très mobilisés ces derniers
jours et je le soulligne encore y
compris s'agissant d'énédis au prix de
la vie d'un des agents qui était
intervenus en Bretagne nous devons
effectivement mieux anticiper encore ces
tempête et nous préparer à faire face à
des ventv comme nous l'avons connu ces
derniers jours mais aussi à des
inondations et j'ai une pensée pour tous
les habitants du pas decalis qui vivent
actuellement des inondations aussi
exceptionnelles je précise que le
ministre de la transition écologique se
rendra demain il pourra rencontrer les
élus et nos concitoyens qui vivent
actuellement ces inondations qui sont
également
exceptionnelles tous ces dérèglements
climatiques doivent nous amener à
anticiper à préparer une meilleure
résilience de nos réseaux c'est tout le
sens du plan national d'adaptation au
changement climatique sur lequel le
ministre de la transition écologique
travaille actuellement en lien avec les
collectivités donc nous sommes au côté
de nos concitoyens qui vivent
aujourd'hui ces dérèglements climatiques
et nous travaillons pour mieux anticiper
et éviter demain d'avoir de nouvelles
difficultés telles que celles que nous
avons vécu ces derniers jours je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
président cqurel pour le groupe la
France
insoumise madame la Première ministre
depuis le 7 octobre 163 Palestiniens ont
été tués en 6jordanie où le Hamas ne se
trouve pas la colonisation s'y renforce
avec son lot de violence armée à Gaza
chiffre repris par l'ONU on compte 10000
civils palestiniens tués dont 4800
enfants et 1,5 million de
déplacés cité dans un article du Monde
un militaire israélien estimé vendre VI
dernier entre plusieurs dizaines et
plusieurs centaines les pertes du Hamas
cette évidente disproportion prouve que
les civils palestiniens ne sont pas
juste des victimes collatérales et
involontaires de représailles contre le
Hamas suite au massacre abominable de ce
dernier les civils palestiniens sont
directement ciblés ces deux situations
la politique coloniale accru en
sixjordanie et le nettoyage ethnique en
cours à Gaza répondent à l'objectif
présenté par Ben netanahou le 23
septembre dernier à l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU au moyen d'une carte absorbant
la sisjordanie et Gaza dans Israël
objectif répété hier quand il assume
qu'Israël prendra la responsabilité
générale de la sécurité à Gaza cette
entreprise n'obéit pas à un prétendu
choc de civilisation cette guerre est
géopolitique en conséquence ne la
transposons pas ici en guerre de
religion l'antisémitisme doit être
combattu comme l'islamophobie et le
racisme l'issue doit être politique
madame la Première ministre lors du
débat parlementaire du 23 octobre vous
sembliez engager la France dans cette
voie trêve humanitaire vers un cesser le
feu impliquant bien sûr la libération de
tous les otages du Hamas ouverture de
négociation pour un plan de paix sur la
base d'une solution à deux états pour
Israël et la Palestine or depuis la
visite du chef de l'État en Israël le
terme même de cesser le feu a quasiment
disparu de votre communication
officielle alors que nous sommes des
millions à exiger un C feu immédiat
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous allez
enfin le reprendre plus nettement à
votre compte si oui quelle est la
feuille de route de la France pour
s'imposer en tant voix pour la paix
merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à Madame chou
zarouou ministre en charge du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux madame la
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés Messieurs les Présidents Corel
la France est fortement préoccupée par
la situation à Gaza et notamment par
l'urgence humanitaire à Gaza comme l'a
souligné la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères ce dimanche nous
appelons sans ambiguité à une trêve
humanitaire
immédiate cette position ferme et claire
nous la tenons aux Nations Unies tant
l'assemblée générale avec l'adoption de
la résolution jordanienne qui au Conseil
de sécurité
le président de la République organise C
JEI à Paris une conférence humanitaire
internationale pour la population civile
de Gaza autour des trois piliers le
respect du droit international
humanitaire de la protection des civils
et du personnel humanitaire une réponse
humanitaire dans le secteur de la santé
de l'eau de l'énergie de l'alimentation
et un appel à mobilisation concrète à
faveur des civils de Gaza
rien dans la lutte antiterroriste
nautorise à abstraire du droit
international humanitaire protéger les
civils et obligation internationale
strict C enfants C infirmièr chaque
journaliste qui Meur dans les frapp à
Gaza et une vie perdue et c'est
insupportable l'emploi des
infrastructures civiles parler en masse
comme site militaire constitue également
une violation du droit international qui
doit être condamné dans les termes le
plus fermes enfin nous condamnons dans
les termes les plus forts les exactions
des nombreux colons qui se multipli
Israël doit faire cesser ces violences
et punir les hauteurs avec la sévérité
qui doit s'attacher à des actes aussi
inacceptables je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur bertr
pour le groupe
Renaissance merciés prid madame la
Première ministre dans la nuit du
mercredi prier au jeudi 2 novembre la
tempête carane a balayé notre pays avec
une violence intense les habitants de
nombreux départements littoraux et je
pense à ceux de mon département de la
Manche ont vécu des heures d'angoisse
face à cette bombe météorologique le
bilan humain est lourd avec tro
personnes décédées et 47 blessés dont de
nombreux pompiers je souhaite à mon tour
ici rendre hommage à cet employé d'énéis
venu en renfort d'occitanier qui a
trouvé la mort samedi soir alors qu'il
travaille pour rétablir l'alimentation
électrique dans le finisterè mes pensées
comme cell de la représentation
nationale s'adresse à sa famille et à
ses proches je souhaite par ailleurs
remercier vivement les services
préfectoraux à l'image du préfet de la
Manche Xavier brunetière les sapeurs
pompiers les forces de l'ordre gendarmes
policiers nationaux et municipaux les
maires et les élus locaux les employés
communaux les soignants tous mobilisés
pour alerter puis pour gérer les
situations de crise créé par ces
intempéries
majeures sans cette anticipation
d'ampleur et cet engagement de tous le
bilan humain aurait vraisemblablement
été encore plus dramatique le bilan
matériel est lui considérable arbre
déracinés tombés sur des maisons ou des
voitures vitres brisées toiture envolé
les assureurs font état de plus de
300000 déclarations de sinistre
enregistré en déplacement en Bretagne
samedi le président de la République a
tenu à rencontrer des personnes
sinistrées pour leur apporter son
soutien il leura d'ailleurs l'activation
rapide de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle ainsi que celui de calamité
agricole permettant tous deux
l'indemnisation systématique des
victimes bien aussi madame la Première
ministre alors qu'un nombre important de
nos concitoyens sont toujours privés
d'électricité pouvez-vous nous confirmer
que tous les départements touchés par la
tempête karane seront bien concernés par
ces deux mesures pouvez-vous éclairer la
représentation nationale sur la date de
publication des décrets au Journal
officiel ainsi que les obligations
imposées aux assur
afin qu'aucun de nos concitoyens touchés
ne soit oublié je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Vig ministre en charge des
outr merci madame la présidente madame
monieur députés monsieur le
député monsieur le député vous avez
rappelé que la Manche avait été très
fortement touché par Siar comme en fait
l'Europe comme le Finistère ça a été dit
à l'instant par la question d' Balan et
notre èg tout à l'heure et vous dire que
les services de l'État ont été présents
massivement ça a été dit par les
parlementaires qui ont posé les
questions 200000 pompiers 13000
interventions ça veut dire que après le
déclenchement de dispositif catastrophe
naturelle on a pris je crois la
dimension de ce véritable drame et que
ce drame comme l'a rappelé la première
ministre il y a eu trois décès
heureusement qu'il y a eu le système
alerte.fr mis en place par le ministère
de l'Intérieur qui qui a permis de
prévenir par SMS tout c ceux qui étaient
dans des situation de fragilité pour la
question que vous posez elle est simple
elle est claire nous avons pris une
décision de placer en catastrophe
naturelle tous les territoires qui
étaient touchés la Commission comme l'a
dit Olivier verérrand se réunira le 14
novembre prochain il appartient aux
communes de constituer les dossier et
pour les sujets agricoles parce que
certains ont tout perdu ont perdu toute
leur activité professionnelle pour de
longs mois il appartient aux exper
maintenant aux assureurs de faire les
diagnostics dans les meilleurs délais et
je vous annonce aujourd'hui que le F de
calamité agricole a été activé de même
que le système assuranciel qui a été mis
en place par ce gouvernement les
agriculteurs ne seront pas oubliés comme
tous ceux qui ont tout perdu nous sommes
là je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Philippe tangy pour le
rassemblement
national madame la Première ministre
contre ma
volonté témoin de la plus effroyable
défaite de la raison et du plus sauvage
triomphe de la brutalité jamais une
génération n'est tombée d'une telle
élévation spirituelle dans une telle
décadence morale quand il écrit ces mots
Stéphan Zwag a fui la barbarie nazie et
un continent submergé par la haine
antisémite que les démocraties n'avaient
pas su étouffer à temps zvag ne ne
survivra pas à une civilisation qu'il
savait défigurer notre civilisation qui
comme l'écrivait Maler et la part de
l'homme que les camps auront voulu
détruire alors que le peuple israélien a
subi les pires atrocités nous devons
constater hélas que le soutien
indéfectible qu'aurait dû recevoir
Israël est meurt par un effroyable
relativisme et une ignoble flambée
d'antisémitisme pire
encore pire encore l'hydre odieuse de la
haine des Juifs ne vient pas s'écraser
contre un mur unanime de bouclier de GL
de nos démocrati pour la battre mais ce
fr un chemin à travers l'indifférence la
lâcheté et le
antisémite suve encore dans le canivau
des extrémismes mais sa source
essentielle sa source cardinal et
désormais l'islamisme l'islamisme ha
souterrain que les nations laissé
s'infiltrer jaill à nos visages et peut
nous submerger faute de réaction à la
hauteur de la catastrophe dans nos rues
nos écoles au sein des médias du sport
de la culture et même des plus grandes
universités la haine des Juifs et
partout de l'insulte jusqu'au meurtre
qu'avons-nous fait du devoir de mémoire
avons-nous oublié que la barbarie
triomphe des illusions de gens de bien
qui pensent vaincre par la simple raison
je dis nous je dis nous car dans un tel
moment aucune division n'est tolérable
Marc bloc affirmé ne revendiquer son
origine que face à un antisémite il est
temps que la France la République
revendique sa civilisation ses valeurs
et son destin contre les antisémites
alors qu'un imam àoker n'a reçu qu'une
peine dérisoire pour avoir professé
laide des Juifs
je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verr porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Tangui l'antisémitisme qui s'exprime sur
les frontons de nos maisons sur les PES
des immeubles dans les injures qui
peuvent être lancées dans les rames de
métro sémitisme qui fait qu'une partie
de nos concitoyens n'os plus faire ses
courses normalement n'os plus mettre ses
enfants dans les écoles normalement n'os
plus aller au travail normalement n'os
plus prendre des transports en commun
normalement cet antisémitisme est un
fléau que nous condamnons tous et que
nous devons combattre avec acharnement
il est
autant il est autant une hérésie
temporaelle qu'
anachronisme cet antisémitisme il n'est
pas né au lendemain du 7 octobre il
avait un antisémitisme pernicieux
insidieux parfois révélé à travers des
actes antisémites je rappelle que la
France déplorait déjà plusieurs
centaines d'actes de cette nature chaque
année cet antisémitisme il croit
désormais dans l'esprit de certain qu'il
serait légitime à exploser au grand jour
comme légitimé par un conflit
israélo-palestinien qui permettrait
enfin à ceux qui ont toujours haïi les
Juifs en secret de pouvoir le faire
cette fois-ci à raison et dans la sphère
publique monsieur le député nous
combattons cet antisémitisme tous ici
dans cet hémicycle monsieur le député je
ne peux je ne peux imaginer qu'un député
de la nation je ne peux imaginer qu'un
député de la nation ne puisse ne puisse
combattre l'antisémitisme mais il n'y a
pas monsieur le député et je le dirai
ici sans polémique il n'y a pas vous
pointez l'extrême gauche je vais vous
pointer vous vous êtes le parti de la
flamme il n'y a pas un bon et anti un
bon et un mauvais antisémitisme il n'y a
qu'un antisémitisme et quand le
président de votre part
il joursuse de reconnaître que président
fondateur de votre parti le Front
national a été condamné par la justice
françaisetisé
pas
serv
alors
[Applaudissements]
conttisés Monsieur
ministre je
vous s'il vous plaît un peu de
silence un peu de silence la parole est
à Madame Marie agès poussier vinbach un
peu de respect pour le collègue suivant
s'il vous plaît la parole est à Madame
Marie agè poussier vinb pour le groupe
horizon madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre une
grande partie du littctoral français a
subi il y a quelques jours surcoup deux
tempêtes de très grande ampleur
aujourd'hui ce sont encore des
inondations des cru qui sont à gérer
dans de nombreux secteurs hélas nous
avons appris que deux personnes étaient
décédées que 47 personnes avaient été
blessées et qu'un agent nd en
intervention avait également trouvé la
mort je voudrais en votre nom adresser à
leur famille toutes nos pensées et
sincères
condoléances malgré ce contexte et grâce
à une information très importante et une
anticipation sans précédent notamment
dans le domaine des transports nous
avons pu éviter une catastrophe plus
importante je voudrais ici rendre
hommage à tous ces hommes et ces femmes
qui ont été et sont encore à cette heure
sur le terrain pour permettre à nos
concitoyens de retrouver ici
l'électricité ici l'eau ici un toit et
particulièrement à ses élus des communes
rurales toujours en première ligne pour
déblayer et réparer les dégâts dans
leurs communes utilisant souvent leur
matériel personnel j'ai pu le constater
tout ce weekend en scène maritime alors
Monsieur le Ministre les dégâts sont
colossaux des toitures envolé des
bâtiments effondrés des arbres tombés
sur des bâtiments publics ou privés des
exploitations agricoles dévastées aussi
le montant des indemnisations devrait-il
être très important ce qui inquiète
aujourd'hui les collectivités ce sont
les montants des primes qui leur sont
demandés pour s'assurer tout simplement
en effet devant la multiplication des
risques certains assureurs se
désengagent et les seules compagnies qui
candidat sont en situation de quasi
monopole vous le savez monsieur le
ministre les tarifs et les franchises
s'envolent nous avons pu constater que
vous aviez confié une mission à Monsieur
Alain chrétien et jean- y dagess qu'en
attendez-vous s'il vous plaît si l'on
souhaite encore avoir des maires en 2026
dans les communes rurales il va nous
falloir trouver des solutions très vite
car les maires ne rempileront pas dans
ces conditions obligés de devenir leurs
propres assureurs avec des allé
climatiques de plus en plus fréquents je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma ch collègue
la parole est à
Monsieur transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la la députée poussier
vincebac je reviens pas sur ce que vous
avez dit et je joins évidemment mon
hommage à tout ce qui a été dit à la
minute de silence et au moment de
solennité que nous avons marqué par
rapport aux victimes de la des tempêtes
et des cru et j'insiste sur le fait que
nous connaissons en ce moment même des
crus qui sont à des niveaux historiques
en particulier dans le Pas de Calais et
que les consignes délivré par les
autorités locales de prudence doivent
être répété à l'envie d'autant que les
prévisions météo n'annoncent pas
d'amélioration de la situation pour les
prochains jours j'aurai l'occasion
demain à la demande de la première
ministre de me rendre sur place vous
pointez les choses sur un cas qui est
celui de l'indemnisation des dommages
par les collectivités trois choses
d'abord à hyper court terme il y a une
clause dans les polices d'assurance pour
la tempête que toutes les collectivités
et tous les particuliers doivent faire
jouer indépendamment de ce que les
l'état pourra décider en fonction des
textes existants le 14 novembre prochain
2 il y a un fond de solidarité qui est
la fusion d'une dotation pour les
collectivités touchées par des
catastrophes naturelles et d'une
dotation pour les collectivités
concernées par des calamités publiques
ce fond permet aux collectivités pour
leurs ouvrages d'art pour leurs
infrastructures pour leurs parc et
jardins pour leurs dig pour leurs
station d'épuration de bénéficier de
crédit qui varient entre 150000 et 6
millions d'euros et qui sont activables
3 le sujet qui est devant nous c'est
l'accélération de ces catastrophes
naturelles contenu du dérèglement
climatique dans ce contexte une mission
spécifique au titre du programme
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique va déboucher avec une mission
conjointe pilotée par Bery qui concerne
aussi bien le retrait gonflement
d'argile que l'érosion du trait de côte
que la multiplication des vagues
submersions et à l'intérieur de ça y
compris compte tenu des émeutes du début
du mois de juillet et compte tenu du
nombre de commune qui cesse de s'assurer
un maire et un assureur devront nous
rendre dans les jours qui viennent une
mission avec des préconisations pour
faire en sorte d'éviter cette explosion
de franchise et concevoir un nouveau
dispositif de soutien au collectivité
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Louis bricou pour le
groupe Yot merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du Logement
monsieur le ministre après 5 années pour
vous convaincre vous avez enfin pris de
bonnes résolutions vous maintenant la
rénovation des logements dans une
approche globale et performante et le
rôle de mon accompagnateur renve est
devenu central dans un parcours de
rénovation ma prime rénove est donc
retoilettée en deux piliers efficacité
et performance et vous multipliez par TR
vos objectif en passant de 70000 à plus
de 200000 rénovations
complèt alors on est encore loin bien
sûr des objectifs du Haut Conseil pour
le climat qui préconise lui 370000
rénovation complète par an mais en tous
les cas la volonté est là d'ailleurs
pour se faire vous annonciez il y a
quelques semaines 1,6 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires à l'ANA pour financer ma
prime renve notamment pour les plus
modestes jusque-l je vais dire tout va
bien mais quand arrive l'examen
budgétaire c'est là que les choses se
gâtent force est de constater que les
crédits dévolu àana ne sont pas au
rendez-vous on a beau fouiller dans vos
budget dans les missions écologie plan
de relance cohésion des territoires il
manque tout de même 700 millions d'euros
vous nous avez indiqué que ces 700
millions d'euros viendrai des recettes
de quôa carbone mais monsieur le
ministre nous les nous les avions déjà
en 2022 ce qui veut dire que ce ne sont
pas des crédits supplémentaires comme
annoncé monsieur le ministre ma question
est toute simple où sont les 700
millions qui manquent à votre parole
merci je vous
remercie la
parole
éat Monsieur Patrice vergriette
ministre en charge du
logement monsieurs les les députés
monsieur le député
bricou effectivement c'est un effort
sans précédent qui est pris par le
engagé par le gouvernement pour
2024 avec bien 5 milliards d'euros
envisagés pour la rénovation énergétique
des logements je vous le confirme
c'est-à-dire bien une hausse de 1,6
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2023 les
700 millions que vous évoquez de quotte
à carbone sont bien dans le projet de
loi de finance et il y a également le
relica effectivement de la trésorie de
l'agence de nationale de l'amélioration
de l'habitat qui permettront à cette
dernière de voter effectivement 4,6
milliards d'euros pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements en 2024
vous le savez à présent puisque je l'ai
déjà évoqué quand il s'agit du logement
locatif social les 400 derniers millions
viendront
abonder le la rénovation du parc social
et donc 400 millions pour le parc social
et 4,6 millions votés par le budget de
l'ANA ça nous fera bien 5 milliards
d'euros pour 2024 je veux rebondir aussi
sur ce que vous avez évoqué à propos des
rénovation globales c'est vrai que
jusqu'à présent ma Prim renove av
essentiellement privilégié du monogeste
c'est vrai que le tournant que nous
prenons et notamment avec les
accompagnateurs qui permettront
d'accompagner
effectivement les propriétaires dans la
rénovation de leur jement c'est de
pouvoir monter cette ambition vous avez
évoqué le chiffre de 200000 rénovation
globale qui est envisagé pour 2024 on
n'est pas encore à 360000 mais c'est un
pas vous l'avez dit dans la bonne
direction donc je vous confirme bien les
5 milliards d'euros prévus pour 2024
merci à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur bricou oui merci monsieur le
ministre de votre réponse mais je vous
le répète les quotas carbones sont pas
des des budgets des recettes
supplémentaires les incertitudes les
flous budgétaires je pense mériterait
quelquefois une réponse un peu plus
précise on a besoin de ces 700 millions
d'euros monsieur monsieur le ministre
pour rénover efficacement nos logements
pour des enjeux écologiques pour des
enjeux sociaux mais aussi pour notre
économie locale de proximité le 49 va
nous priver de débat budgétaire
malheureusement ne vous privez pas de
ces crédits ne nous privez pas de ces
crédits et inscrivez ces 700 milli
millions d'euros fermement au budget
merci bra merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Céline
calves pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Gabrielle Atal ministre de
l'éducation nationale depuis votre prise
de fonction en juillet dernier vous avez
fait de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire une des priorités de votre
action en tant que ministre de
l'Éducation ainsi votre engagement total
a permis la libération de témoignages
ces témoignages nous les avons parfois
retrouvé parfois découvert et oui il
faut témoigner témoigner des tourments
incessessants de leur prolongement
également dans l'espace numérique
témoigner pour mieux dire stop stop au
harcèlement témoigner parce qu'on est
victime témoigner parce qu'on l'a été
même des années après témoigner pourquoi
pas aussi parce qu'on a harcelé parfois
sans le vouloir parfois sans le savoir
témoigner aussi parce que l'on est
témoin on est tous témoins du
harcèlement d'autres personnes sur
d'autres personnes détecter la situation
pour mieux la régler c'est aussi ça la
vigilance partagée le incement
n'implique pas seulement une relation
entre un auteur et une victime l'
réduire ce serait encore plus isolé or n
d'orénavant personne ne doit être seul
face au harcèlement le harcèlement
implique toute la communauté communauté
éducative communauté nationale aussi et
c'est toute notre communauté que vous
avez invité à se mobiliser ce jeudi 9
novembre dans 2 jours c'est la Journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
dans tous les établissements scolaires
de France vous aviez évoqué des heures
banalisées pour permettre à toutes et à
tous d'échanger vous aviez également
parlé d'un questionnaire
d'autoévaluation pour mieux détecter ces
situations à l'école pouvez-vous nous
les préciser nous préciser comment va se
dérouler cette journée et au-delà même
de cette journée jeudi et parce que je
connais votre attachement à cultiver
l'empathie que prévoyez-vous en ce sens
auprès des élèves de leur enseignants
mais également auprès des parents je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel hatal ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Céline Calvez vous l'avez dit
cette semaine est une semaine décisive
dans le combat que nous menons contre le
harcèlement sous l'autorité de la
première ministre et qui s'est
concrétisé par le plan que la première
ministre a présenté il y a plusieurs
semaines chaque année il y a une journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
en général elle réunit autour d'un tiers
des établissements qui organisent des
actions autour du harcèlement cette
année nous avons voulu que cette journée
soit inédite par son ampleur très
concrètement à partir de jeudi prochain
les cours s'arrêteront pendant 2 heures
dans toutes les classes de France pour
avoir un temps dédié à la lutte contre
le harcèlement très concrètement les
équipes éducatives avec les élèves
échangeront sur le phénomène du
harcèlement très concrètement aussi sera
proposé à tous les élèves un outil
d'autoévaluation du harcèlement cet
outil ce questionnaire on l'a construit
avec des spécialistes de la santé
mentale de l'enfant de l'adolescent des
spécialistes du climat scolaire je pense
au professeur Marcel ruffau à Éric de
Barbieux au docteur Nicole Katheline
parce que on se rend compte
malheureusement que des élèves qui
peuvent subir le harcèlement finissent
sans parfois même se rendre compte par
élever leur seuil de tolérance et
accepter des choses qui ne peuvent pas
être accepté pour se protéger eux-mêmees
ce questionnaire il va permettre
probablement de libérer encore davantage
la parole il va nous permettre aussi à
nous de bénéficier de données
actualisées au niveau national les
dernières données dont nous disposons
sur le harcèlement datent de 2011 TikTok
snapchat n'existait pas à l'époque donc
c'est une journée très importante et
j'invite évidemment les parlementaires à
se mobiliser aussi mais nous allons
continuer à aller plus loin vous l'avez
dit développement de temps dédiés à
l'apprentissage de l'autre de la
différence de la tolérance de la
bienveillance dans toute nos écoles
primaires dès la rentrée de septembre
prochain et dans une école par
département à partir de janvier et enfin
pour les parents en janvier 2024 un
module numérique pour les accompagner
dans le repérage des signaux faibles du
harcèlement à la maison c'était aussi
une demande très forte de leur part vous
le voyez première ministre a présenté un
plan il y a une mobilisation collective
et on continue à avancer je vous
remercie merci
[Musique]
beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Présidente châelin pour le group
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre laissez-moi
vous citer en tant que garde des saut
Éric Dupont moriti a toute ma confiance
et fait un excellent travail telle était
votre déclaration hier sur France
interre je conçois qu'il est difficile
pour vous d'admettre une nouvelle
affaire qui touche votre gouvernement
nouvelle et pas des moindres le ministre
de la Justice poursuivi par sa propre
justice c'est cfcayen c'est une
plaisanterie à part dans une République
où on a Emmanuel Macron comme président
et oui c'est possible c'est une première
dans la 5e République félicitations
continuez de congratuler votre garde des
saau pour son excellent travail un garde
des saau qui est soupçonné d'avoir
utilisé son ministère et les services
qui en dépendent pour régler ses comptes
un garde des saau qui depuis juillet
2021 est obsédé par sa défense un
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel huit pourvoies en
cassation ce qui représente des heures à
éplucher la jurisprudence de rendez-vous
avec ses avocats des heures pour
préparer sa défense des heures où il
n'est pas ministre un garde des saut qui
pendant 15 jours sera empêché dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions un garde des
saau qui s'autorise non pas un mais deux
bras d'honneur dans cet hémicycle parce
qu'un président de groupe ose évoquer
finalement la procédure en cours un
garde desceau qui se pose en victime et
qui ose parler d'infamie quand son
action est interrogée madame la Première
ministre la jurisprudence baladure un
ministre mis en examen il démissionne
avait une raison d'être garantir qu'un
ministre s'attache pleinement
complètement au service des Français et
au service de l'État donc ma question
madame la Première ministre elle est
simple finalement qu'est-ce que ça fait
depuis mai 2022 de diriger un
gouvernement sans garde au D
saau je vous remercie la parole est à
madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre puté madame la Présidente
châelin il y a dans notre État de droit
un principe auquel je tiens c'est la
présomption
d'innocence j'imagine madame la
Présidente châelin que vous y êtes
également attaché alors le ministre de
la Justice comme toutes et tous y a
droit le procès s'est ouvert hier et il
durera jusqu'au 16
novembre sur une affaire à une procédure
en cours comme vous l'imaginez je ne
vais faire aucun commentaire et pendant
cette période des mesures pratiques
classiques d'organisation ont été prise
donc je vous rassure la continuité de
l'État et de l'action gouvernementale
est bien assurée et je vous le redis
madame la président de châelin comme
garde des saut Éric Dupont morti à toute
ma confiance je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre
madame la Présidente merci madame la
Présidente oui comm tous ici nous sommes
attachés à la présomption d'innocence
mais la question est ce gouvernement
est-il attaché au principe de probité
aujourd'hui apparemment la réponse est
NON je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Josiane
cornelou pour le groupe les républicain
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre les
attaques du loup se multiplient j'étais
déjà intervenu il y a 3 ans pour alerter
le gouvernement sur l'impossible
cohabitation dans le bocage charolet
briillonnais de ce prédateur avec un
mode d'élevage pastoral traditionnel la
surprotection dont bénéficie aujourd'hui
le loup a entraîné sa prolifération et
désespère des éleveurs auovin beauin qui
voit souvent des années de sélection
génétique anéanti par la répétition
d'actes de prédation pour la première
fois en sonnéloire berceau de l'élevage
des chevaux ont été il y a quelques
jours victimes du loup une poliouce de
18 mois agonisante a dû être euthanasié
mais de ce bien-être animal les tenants
de la réintroduction des grands
prédateurs ne soufflent mot et pourtant
c'est un drame pour ce couple d'éleveur
qui a travaillé jour et nuit afin de
faire de son Hara le plus important des
Arabes privés de pursant anglais de
Bourgogne cette réussite est aujourd'hui
fragilisée d'une part par la perte de
cette pouliche issue d'une très belle
souche qui échappe à toutbê
d'indemnisation mais surtout par la
crainte de certains propriétaires qui
redoutant les récidives ne veulent plus
mettre leurs chevaux en pension la
version actuelle du prochain plan
national loup continue d'ignorer
l'ampleur du problème et semble reléguer
au second plan le sort des éleveur à qui
elle propose un accompagnement
psychologique monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas une aide psychologique dont
ont besoin les éleveurs mais de mesures
fortes qui témoignent du soutien de
l'État au monde agricole des mesures à
même ce qui s'apparente de plus en plus
à un fléo créé par des citadains
ignorant tout des réalités rurales
allez-vous par conséquent monsieur le
ministre instaurer une indispensable
procédure d'abattage rapide sans passer
par l'étape de la gradation des tirs
comme cela se fait déjà en Autriche et
en Suisse allez-vous permettre à des
éleveurs à la fois dépités et en colère
de retrouver la sécurité et la sérénité
sans lesqueles beaucoup renonceront à
leur beau métier allez-vous écoutez la
voix des
merci madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée cornelou effectivement vous
êtes plusieurs députés à m'avoir saisi
de ces questions sur la prédation du
loup d'abord dire vous avez raison que
ça n'est pas principalement un préjudice
économique que subissent les éleveurs
c'est souvent un préjudice psychologique
et le sentiment qui n'arriveront pas à
poursuivre leur activité d'vage dans un
certain nombre de territoires vous êtes
dans un département qui est particulier
parce que c'est un département qu'on
considère comme un un front de
colonisation le Lou est réapparu en
2019 les attaques se sont multipliées il
y a eu 215 animaux qui ont été tués par
des loups cette année et nous sommes
encore 219 je crois et nous sommes
encore en cours d'année sur le plan loup
actuel et je parlerai après du plan loup
futur nous avons décider de renforcer
les les les moyens présents sur le
territoire en particulier la brigade
loup qui a été là plusieurs semaines qui
va être là la semaine qui vient pour
faire en sorte que le tir les tirs qui
sont prévus puissent être effectués par
les les la brigade loup parce qu'on sait
que dans les zones de colonisation les
fronts de colonisation on a des sujets
de professionnalisation on a besoin
aussi que les louftiers puissent se
former les brigades lou sont là pour le
faire on avait d'ailleurs renforcé je
dis ça sous l'œil de mon collègue Béchu
la brigade puisqu'il y a deux brigades
maintenant qui sont présentes en France
deuxième élément sur le plan loup le
futur plan loup celui qui se déploiera à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 on a essayé
de tenir une position d'équilibre
première position c'est de faire en
sorte comp tenu de l'évolution de la
population c'est un travail que nous
avons fait je le signale en bonne
collaboration avec le ministère de la
transition écologique c'était bien que
nous puissions travailler travailler de
concer sur ce sujet premier élément
réinterroger la question du statut du
loup parce que il y a un effectif à
partir duquel au niveau européen on peut
se poser la question de est-ce qu'il
faut pas faire évoluer ce statut
deuxième élément et ça vous concerne en
particulier dans votre département la
question de la non protégeabilité d'un
certain nombre de troupeaux vous êtes
dans une zone où il faut reconnaître
qu'il n'y a pas forcément la possibilité
de protéger les troupeau cont tenu du
bocage de la densité et du type
d'élevage trème élément la prise en
charge des pertes indirectes ça concerne
y compris parce que pour l'instant il n
avait que les pertes directes qui
étaient concerné 4è élément
la simplification des tirs parce que ça
aussi ça permettra de le faire et donc
voilà les éléments qu'on a posé dans le
plan Lou qui é soumis à la consultation
qui permettra je le crois de trouver des
perspectives plus sereines pour les
agriculteurs pour les éleveurs qui
souffrent beaucoup de trop préationci
beaucoup Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Madame Caroline
Fiat pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre hier je lis sur les
réseaux sociaux il est 11h25 en France
les femmes travaillent désormais
gratuitement jusqu'à la fin de l'année
mixité des métiers orientation
professionnelle accès au postees à
responsabilité égalité salariale nous
devons agir sur tous les Levi j'y
veillerai je me dis quel programme
quelle ambition quelle volonté politique
voilà quelqu'un qui mériterait d'être
responsabilité je prends le temps de
regarder l'auteur vous quelle hypocrisie
sur la mixité des métiers 92 % des
assistantes maternelles 97 % des aides
soignantes sont des femmes vous espérez
que cela change par la formation
professionnelle mais aujourd'hui il y a
près de 90 % de femmes dans les filières
sanitaires et sociales qui sont les plus
mal rémunérées souvent en temps partiel
subit quel hypocrie pour l'accès au
postees à responsabilité vous pourrez au
moins vous satisfaire d'être première
ministre alors même que pendant l'examen
du PLFSS en commission nous avons fait
des propositions pour aboutir à
l'égalité salariale résultat rien les
écarts de salaire entre les femmes et
les hommes ne se réduisent quasiment pas
et si le rythme actuel est maintenu les
femmes devraient gagner autant que les
hommes d'ici
2234 quel sens des priorités nous
proposions par exemple que l'accès aux
subventions public et aux exonérations
de cotisation soi réservé aux structures
respectant strictement l'égalité
salariale et pourtant vos députés ont
voté contre quelle hypocrisie madame la
Première ministre obnubilé par l'idée
d'atteindre l'égalité de 493 entre les
femmes et les hommes vous en oubliez
l'essentiel les propositions de vos
oppositions alors ma question est simple
maintenant que vous avez fini de veiller
quand comptez-vous réellement
agir je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier duop ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
madame la députée Fiat je pense que nous
pouvons nous retrouver d'abord sur un
premier constat le fait que les
inégalités salariales sont inacceptables
et le principe d'égalité salariale qui a
été posé en 1972 pose encore un certain
nombre de difficultés puisquil n'est pas
parfaitement respecté et sur les
inégalités de salaire que nous savons
expliquer il y a une partie qui relève
de discrimination de culture de la
discrimination entre femmes et hommes
qui n'est pas acceptable que
pouvons-nous faire face à cela d'abord
conforter ce que nous avons déjà
commencé à faire nous avons depuis 2019
un index qui mesure l'égalité
professionnelle et cela s'est accompagné
de 772 mises en demeur et des 45
premières pénalités nous avons voté en
2021 vous avez voté une loi sur des
femmes aux responsabilités dans les plus
grandes entreprises nous veillons
évidemment à cette bonne mise en œuvre
mais il faut aller plus loin et aller
plus loin cela passe par les chantiers
que nous avons ouvert avec la première
ministre et ma collègue beréranger
Couillard lors de la conférence sociale
aller plus loin c'est lutter contre le
temps partiel subi ça sera une priorité
du ha conseil des rémunération parce que
le temps partiel subi est une des
premières explications de cette grande
différence entre le salaire des hommes
et le salaire des femmes aller plus loin
c'est faire en sorte que cet index sur
l'égalité professionnelle femme homme
soit évalué révisé pour être amélioré
plus cooheritif et ainsi être plus
efficace et enfin les plus loin c'est
mettre en œuvre les dispositions de la
directive européenne sur la transparence
et l'égalité salariale la France a
jusqu'à fin 2026 pour la mettre en œuvre
nous avons dit avec madame la Première
ministre avec Madame la déléguée en
charge de l'égalité femme hommes que
cette dispositif sera transposé d'ici
202 d'ici début 2025 je ne doute pas
pouvoir compter sur votre soutien je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la
députée l'avantage d'être élu madame la
Première ministre c'est que notre
indemnité n'est pas pénalisée par
l'inégalité salariale femme homme nous
ne sommes pas bénévoles depuis hier
matin vous auriez pu me répondre sachez
tout de même que l'application de
l'égalité salariale financerait les
retraites et permettrait aux Français de
pouvoir partir à la retraite à 60 ans
ambitieux
non je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur Éric
pouya pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur dans
quelques jours nous nous remémorons les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 malgré
notre réponse ferme l'islam radical
continue de se déployer en France et
dans le monde il a choisi ses ennemis et
les désigne les laïques les
intellectuels les femmes les homosexuels
les Juifs tous les républicains tous les
démocrates sont visés car cette
idéologie haineuse n'a qu'un ennemi
notre République héritiè des lumières et
ses combat pour la liberté et
l'émancipation il en a frappé les
symboles les visages nos soldats nos
policiers et gendarmes nos
enseignants il y a 8 ans presque jour
pour jour il a frappé le cœur battant de
notre société notre jeunesse et cherche
encore à la
manipuler l'islamisme n'a qu'un projet
détruire notre démocratie il n'a qu'un
moyen radicaliser les esprits et les
faire basculer dans la violence et la
terreur depuis des décennies nous
apprenons nous nous adaptons nous
réagissons aujourd'hui plus que jamais
face aux actes antisémites que subissent
nos compatriotes Juifs aucune voix
républicaine ne peut manquer dans ce
combat nous devons nous battre pour que
nous puissions vivre nos croyances et
convictions intimes en nous respectant
pour que les visages de la République ne
se sentent plus abandonné mais soutenu
et porté par tout un peuple pour que
notre jeunesse reprenne le flambeau des
lumières convaincu que elles seules
garantiront leur émancipation dans nos
écoles et nos universités dans nos
services publics nos clubs de sport nos
familles nous devons nous battre pour
notre commun et refuser une société des
communautés quelles sont vos actions
monsieur le ministre pour
RER à une repost partagée de lutte
contre l'islamisme pour qu'enfin nous
retrouvions le chemin du commun celui
d'un peuple au multiples facettes mais
uni par une même fraternité dans l'amour
de la
République je vous remercie monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Sabrina
Agresti rouage ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Éric pouya je
partage entièrement votre analyse sur ce
travail de SAP de l'islamisme radical
qui se déploie dans toutes les sphères
de la société dans nos quartiers
populaires dans les services publics
dans le tissu associatif dans les
pratiques spores
ou encore à l'école de la République
face à ce danger le président de la
République a appelé lors de son discours
au Mureau le 2 octobre 2020 à défendre
avec force les valeurs de la République
de notre République à nous opposer au
repli communautairire et au séparatisme
monsieur le député le gouvernement a
déployé une stratégie globale vous le
savez de lutte contre le séparatisme
islamiste qui vise à entraver toutes les
initiatives contraires aux fondamentaux
et au fondement de notre République à
amplifier l'ensemble des actions pour
l'égalité des chances sur tous les terr
territoire et accompagner les la
structuration du culte musulman dans
notre pays face aux dérives extrémistes
de l'islamisme je veux également
rappeler que une loi fondamentale dans
la lutte contre le séparatisme islamiste
a été votée le 24 août 2021 près de
30000 opérations de contrôle ont été
effectuées par les services 1072
établissements séparatistes fermés à
titre temporaire ou ou définitif 780
signalement par les préfets au titre de
l'article 40 949 étranger radicalisé
expulsé ou maintenu hors du territoire
monsieur le député face à l'islamisme
radical le gouvernement est plus que
jamais mobilisé vous pouvez compter sur
toute ma détermination et ça je je vous
regarde je vous le dis parce que vous
connaissez mes combats pour lutter pied
à pied contre toutes les atteintes à nos
valeurs et à nos principes fondamentaux
de notre République je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Fréd
le groupe
GDR madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ma question est un cri
un cri d'alerte aussi fort que la
situation est urgente en hexagone mais
aussi chez moi à la Réunion où les TPE
PME représent 95 % duud économique et
elles sont en souffrance le cri d'alerte
des syndicats CS a et er TPE qui
représente ses hommes et ses femmes
courageux ses carleurs ses boulangers
ses plombiers chees charquitiers qui se
lèv chaque matin pour faire tourner
l'économie réonnaise ces TPE PME sont
les premiers employeurs de l'île mais
ces hommes et ces femmes croulent ils
croulent sous le poids des charges
sociales et non'ont plus les moyens de
venir à bout des dépenses en raison des
caractères inéquitables de leur taxation
si l'on ne fait rien c'est 15000
entreprises qui risquent la fermeture
avec des conséquences néfastes sur
l'emploi sur un territoire qui compte
déjà 18 % de chômage les TPE PME
méritent autant d'intérêt que les géants
de l'économie réonnaise oui vous avez
aidé Air Austral oui vous avez aidé run
market maintenant les TPE PME attendent
le même soutien et la même volonté que
d'aider à travers cette crise vous avez
aidé Goliath il faut maintenant aider
David plus récemment des annonces de
l'Inspection Générale des Finances ont
été traduites dans un amendement soutenu
par votre majorité qui prévoit de
supprimer des mécanismes de
défiscalisation destiné aux sociétés
ultramarines c'est un nouveau coubat pé
à nos entreprises locales madame la
ministre je sais pouvoir compter sur
vous quand il s'agit de défendre
l'économie etcholonner voir supprimer
les dettes suspendre les poursuites le
temps de permettre l'ppurement du passif
réadapter le système de calcul de
cotisation aux économies insulaires
maintenir le système de défiscalisation
voilà la solution que je vous demande de
considérer madame la ministre être vous
prête à disposer et à écouter ce cri
d'alarme pour défendre il faut faut
comprendre je vous invite à venir dans
nos territoires pour voir que l'État
doit apporter son soutien au TPE PME je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
ministre en charge des
outremes merci madame la Présidente
mesames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député maillot je vrais vous dire que
avec Olivier Grégoire on soutient depuis
longtemps les PME les TPE les PMI les
ETI parce que ce sont celles qui sont
les plus pourvoyess d'emploi et en part
particulier dans le département que vous
avez l'honneur de représenter
c'est-à-dire la Réunion si l'année 2022
est une très belle année notamment dans
le domaine du tourisme création de de 20
% d'emplois 6 % d'augmentation
d'activité dans l'industrie 5 %
d'agriculture 2023 oui c'est difficile
et comme c'est difficile nous avons
renforcé vous savez puisque vous avez
été très présent hier soir sur les
débats sur l'outreemire puisque
s'agissait du budget des outremè je vous
rappelle quand même et vous le savez
monsieur le député les exonérations de
charges dites l'OM sont amplifiés en
2024 vous savez également que dans les
zones franches il y a des nouveau
secteurs d'activité qui berront encore
des meilleures défiscalisations qui
interviendront en 2024 vous savez que
nous travaillons sur la vie chè
notamment avec la réforme de TR de mer
vous savez que nous travaillons
également sur la Ve chè au travers de la
mission sur les monopoles qui a été
lancé avec Bruno Le Maire avec Gérald
armmanin avec moi-même pour faire en
sorte que les PME TPE soit mieux protégé
vous savez aussi que nous travaillons
sur quelque chose de très important et
on va aboutir je le dis à tous les
députés qui sont présents ici c'est la
fameuse norme RUP région
ultrapériphérique qui va remplacer cette
fameuse norme CE c'est que les matériaux
seront beaucoup moins cher ça fait 20
ans qu'on attend cette réforme là au
mois de mars 2024 nous serons au bout du
chemin et je vois que vous le
reconnaissez ça a été tellement
difficile pour y arriver et nous allons
y arriver un effort également pour la
formation et parce que cette formation
est dépendante comme vous le savez aussi
de la mobilité c'est pour ça qu'on
augmente de 30 % les crédits de mobilité
pour 2024 et enfin sur l'innovation à la
Réunion c'est une terre d'innovation
j'étais il y a quelques semaines vous
savez dans votre département région et
j'ai vu à quel point il y avait des
start-up très innovante je serai à
nouveau le 30 novembre comptez sur moi
pour soutenir plus encore les start-up
parce que ces start-ups sont aussi ça
montre le dynamisme et le ryement de
l'économie ultramarine qui mérite d'être
soutenu merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Laurent jacobelli pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la Culture cite en
ce moment il y a le déguisement
netanahou qui marche pas mal une sorte
de nazi mais sans prépus où a-t-on
entendu ces propos infâmes dans un
meeting de la France insoumise ou dans
une manifestation propalestinienne pas
tout à fait mais presque c'était sur
France interre une radio du service
public français dont vous avez la
tutelle depuis l'ignoble attaque du
Hamas contre Israël il y a tout juste un
mois plus de 1000 actes d'antisémitisme
ont été dénombré en France c'est le
moment que Guillaume mauris ce comique
troupier de l'abject a choisi pour
comparer les juifs au nazis pour
transformer les victimes en bourreaux
l'hostilité envers nos concitoyens de
confessions juifes s'est glissé partout
le sport la culture l'Assemblée
nationale même et vous mê et aussi les
médias madame la ministre vous semblez y
assister impuissante comment pouvez-vous
tolérer que les impôts des Français
servent à financer l'antisémitisme dans
l'audiovisuel public après y avoir
largement financé le wisme et
l'islamogauchisme Guillaume meuis a
récolté d'un simple avertissement ce
n'est évidemment pas à la hauteur du mal
qui ronge notre société votre mutisme
non plus d'ailleurs pas étonnant vous
n'aviez rien dit pour condamner l'emploi
de journaliste antisémite sur France 24
ni même quand la FP refusait de
qualifier le Hamas de mouvement
terroriste ce qu'il est après ce nouveau
scandale allez-vous rester encore
mutique oou allez-vous enfin prendre des
mesures concrètes pour chasser cet
antisémitisme qui se cache dans certains
recoins sombres du service public de
l'audiovisuel
français je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Abd mal ministre de la
Culture merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député je rappelle dans
despl au rassemblement national que la
presse est indépendante dans notre pays
qu'il y a une liberté éditoriale total
de l'audiovisuel public comme
privé qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans ce
cas précis ne réduisit pas TR mots d'un
animateur
humoriste l'ensemble de la politique de
l'audiovisuel qui est menée sous la
houlette de la présidente cbilvel
Charline vanoncker a publié productrice
de l'émission un message où elle s'est
dit profondément navré elle a rappelé
que l'antisémitisme est une abomination
qui n'a pas sa place dans son émission
adelle vanret la directrice de France
interre a également publié un message en
disant qu'une limite a été franchie pas
celle du droit qu'il reste à établir
mais celle du respect de la dignité la
présidente de radio France a pris une
sanction disciplinaire elle a aussi
envoyé un message à l'ensemble des
équipes de Radio France pour rappeler
l'exigence de responsabilité de rigueur
et de modération l'arcom a été saisi oui
monsieur le député l'audiovisuel est
régulé par une autorité indépendante
dans notre pays pas par le
politique dans un état de droit ce n'est
pas à la ministre de la Culture de
choisir les animateurs les chroniqueurs
ni de contrôler leurs propos
rendra sa décision et évidemment pour ce
qui est de mon engagement total dans la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme au côté de
tous mes collègues du gouvernement je ne
reviens pas là-dessus nous continuons ce
combat tous les
jours merci madame la ministre monsieur
jacobelli madame la ministre vous avez
l'indignation sélective vous étiez plus
lecass pour condamner la nomination d'un
nouveau rédacteur en chef pour un
journal privé vous étiez plus Locass
pour condamner une chaîne d'information
privée vous étiez plus Locass pour
condamner une émission de divertissement
d'un groupe privé mais là par hasard
lorsqu'il s'agit de condamner
l'antisémitisme du service public il n'y
a plus personne Quiot consent c'est
votre responsabilité madame la ministre
et vous l'assumez
pas merci monsieur le député madame la
ministre monsieur le député c'est vous
qui avez l'insulte sélective moi quand
je je j'interviens jamais vous pouvez
reprendre tous mes tweets toutes mes
intertions je n'ai jamais commenté les
propos d'cun animateur à aucun moment je
rappelle à chaque fois le cadre de la
loi les obligations qu'une chaîne
notamment de la TNT chaîne gratuite doit
respecter et c'est à l'arcom autorité
indépendante de faire son travail et
dans le cas présent elle est en train de
le faire je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole s'il vous plaît un
peu de silence la parole est à Madame
mariecharlotte Garin pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le ministre en ce
moment dans notre pays qui se tient
fièrement parmi les premières économies
du monde une réalité sombre et
insupportable ébranle nos consciences
des milliers d'appels au 115 restent
sans réponse laissant plus de 2800
enfants sans abri des enfants des
enfants exposés au froid à l'insécurité
à la précarité à Lyon et ailleurs des
citoyens des enseignants et des élèv
s'organise goûter solidaire occupation
d'école il comble l'espace que vous
n'arrivez pas à occuper faute de
moyens l'abbé Pierre disait le contraire
de la misère ce n'est pas la richesse le
contraire de la misère c'est le partage
ce que nous voulons ça n'est pas la
charité nous voulons du travail et des
logements dignes pour tous vous vous
donnez des milliards aux entreprises
chaque année sans contrepartie et vous
menez une politique qui appauvrit les
gens qui ne sont déjà pas bien riches
baisse des aPL précarisation des
chômeurs casse du Code du travail coût
budgétaire y compris dans certains
services sociaux vous êtes allé jusqu'à
criminaliser l'occupation des logements
vacants alors évidemment les budgets
alloués à l'hébergement d'urgence n'ont
jamais été aussi haut mais parce que la
situation n'a jamais été aussi
catastrophique il y a 2822 enfants qui
dorment dans les rues de notre pays ce
que nous ne voulons ce n'est pas la
charité mais il y a urgence la semaine
dernière nous avons voté l'augmentation
des places d'hébergement d'urgence en
commission des finances avec des députés
de tout bord politique monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple vous
engagez-vous à maintenir la création de
ces place dans le budget final que vous
allez faire adopter malgré le 493 je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Patrice vergrit ministre en
charge du
logement madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée
Garin aucun gouvernement aucun
gouvernement n'a créé autant de places
d'hébergement d'urgence aucun
gouvernement nous sommes aujourd'hui à
plus de 203000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence et nous continuons encore à
les
augmenter avec le plan logement d'abord
approuvé par toutes les associations ces
440000 personnes à la rue qui ont
retrouvé un logement et nous continuons
aujourd'hui ce travail ce matin j'ai eu
l'occasion d'annoncer 500 postes
supplémentaires 500 postes
supplémentaires un/ers des effectifs
madame la député pour la veille sociale
le 115 que vous évoquez les marodes que
vous évoquez aussi également tout
l'accompagnement social pour permettre à
ces personnes non pas de rester dans
l'ébergement d'urgence parce que nous
non nous neous en satisfons pas nous 2
ans 5 ans dans l'hébergement d'urgence
ça ne nous va pas augmenter les places
d'hébergement d'urgence ça ne nous va
pas nous nous voulons trouver des
solutions pour qu'il puisse trouver un
logement et c'est ça que nous faisons
actuellement et c'est pour ça que nous
remontons ces effectifs là avec des
solutions de logement à la clé
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre madame la
députée simplement vous rappelez que
l'année dernière on a dû se battre
contre la suppression de 14000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence que les les
places d'hébergement d'urgence ne soient
pas une baguette magique on le sait mais
là face à l'urgence on a besoin de
solution est-ce que vous confirmez que
vous n'allez pas maintenir la création
ces place d'hébergement du gen est-ce
que c'est ça la réponse que vous
apportez aux 2800 enfants qui dorment à
la rue aujourd'hui dans notre pays je
vous
remercie la parole est à présent à
Madame Sarah tanzilet pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question à laquelle j'associe la
délégation aux droits des femmes
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
depuis ce lundi à 11h25 et ce jusqu'à la
fin de l'année les femmes travaillent
gratuitement derrière ce chiffre issu
d'un calcul établi par la newsletter les
glorieuses il faut voir une inégalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes persistantes et multifactorielle
à fonction étant de travail équivalent
d'abord la différence de revenu entre
les femmes et les hommes tombe sous les
5 % ce différentiel peut et doit être
traité par la mise sous pression des
entreprises peu vertueuses en la matière
c'est l'objet de l'index de l'égalité
professionnelle mis en place en 2018 par
cette majorité forcer les changements de
ement en obligeant les entreprises à
calculer d'abord le niveau d'inégalité
de genre en leur sein puis à l'assumer
publiquement à équivalent temps plein
identique seette fois les femmes sont
effectivement payées en moyenne 15 % de
moins que les hommes pourquoi parce
qu'elles occupent des emplois souvent
moins rémunérateurs qui ne sont pourtant
pas les moins importants de notre
société 90 % des infirmières sont des
femmes 87 % des sages-femmes sont des
femmes 67 % des enseignants sont des
enseignantes il nous faut donc
revaloriser ces métiers et encourager
les femmes à rejoindre des filières de
formation plus rémunératrices notamment
technique et scientifique qu'ell ne
s'autorise pas encore suffisamment à
emprunter enfin les femmes sont
également très souvent touchées par le
temps partiel souvent subi on nous
répond qu'il est aussi choisi mais
est-ce vraiment un choix lorsqu'elles y
ont recours pour avoir le temps de
s'acquitter de leur second emploi
domestique non rémunéré celui-là madame
la Première ministre l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes est déterminante pour
l'indépendance des femmes et pour lutter
contre les violences économiques
conjugales pourtant malgré des avancées
dans ce domaine notamment l'allongement
du congé paternité la situation demeure
insatisfaisante aussi ma question est la
suivante quelle mesures supplémentaires
comptez-vous prendre pour réduire les
inégalités salariales entre les femmes
et les hommes je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Beranger
Couillard ministre en charge de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
discriminations merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée tanzili 15 %
c'est ce que pèse la société patriarcale
sur le revenu salarial des femmes trop
de femmes sont cantonnées au métier peu
valorisés trop de femmes subissent les
temps partiels et la maternité constitue
encore pour trop de femmes un facteur de
précarité mais aussi de frein dans leur
carrière notre action elle repose sur
quatre piliers atteindre l'égalité
salariale briser le plafond de verre
améliorer la mixité des métiers et
également rééquilibrer la charge
parentale nous avons déjà beaucoup agi
nous avons facilité l'accès des femmes
aux postes à responsabilité dans le
secteur privé comme public avec
l'installration de quotas revaloriser
les métiers féminisés grâce aux segéures
de la santé et aux Grenelles de
l'éducation également améliorer les
congés maternité et paternité et avec
horur berger nous déployons le service
public de la petite enfance pour lutter
contre les inégalités salariales parce
que c'est bien le sujet nous avons mis
en place un index d'égalité
professionnelle qui impose aux
entreprises une obligation de résultats
et non plus seulement de moyens cette
priorité elle a été réaffirmée par la
première ministre lors de la conférence
sociale et cet index il sera retravaillé
et également renforcé dans les 18
prochains mois il permettra également la
mise en place de l'éga
conditionitionnalité de la commande
publique nous aurons alors un outil plus
ambitieux plus transparent et également
plus fiable et mieux contrôlé et cet
outil doit devenir un outil pour la
négociation d'entreprise les femmes
elles doivent aussi se tourner vers les
métiers d'avenir qui sont mieux ér c'est
tout l'enjeu du programme Tech pour
toutes que je porte et qui a l'objectif
d'accompagner 10000 jeunes femmes dans
les études supérieurs dans la tech alors
madame la députée soyez assuré de mon
engagement également celui du
gouvernement pour faire reculer chaque
année cette date également les
inégalités qu'ell
reflètent je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame marine
amelet pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture monsieur F je souhaite
aujourd'hui être le porte-parole des
agriculteurs du
terngaron que j'ai rencontré à travers
leurs représentants syndicaux vendredi
dernier leur exaspération est à son
comble depuis votre prise de fonction
vous n'avez quasiment rien fait la
situation s'est détériorer à votre
propos les agricultures les agriculteurs
disent je les cite il nous écoute mais
il ne nous entend pas ainsi donc
monsieur le ministre les belles paroles
que vous leur tenez restent lettre morte
pourtant les problèmes vous les
connaissez concurrence déloyale avec les
autres pays ce qui est interdit chez
nous est autorisé
ailleurs normes
punitives persécutions administratives
augmentation des prix de l'énergie et du
GNR augmentation de 60 % de la redevance
sur l'eau dans notre département cela va
condu ire vous le savez à des milliers
de faillites d'après les syndicats
d'agriculteurs dans les deux prochaines
années la moitié des exploitations du
tarnégaron auront
disparu mettez-vous à la place monsieur
le ministre de ces agriculteurs de ces
hommes de ces femmes qui ont reçu une
exploitation de leurs parents de leurs
grands-parents et qui demain ne pourront
les transmettre à leurs enfants les
agriculteurs sont pris en tenaille entre
la hausse des coups de production et la
baisse des prix de vente avez-vous
conscience que cette profession est à
l'agonie il faut prendre des mesures
concrètes efficaces et durables pour
sauver une profession qui vous le savez
assure notre souveraineté alimentaire
merci monsieur le ministre de nous de
nous préciser ce que le gouvernement
compte faire en urgence pour nos
agriculteurs je vous remercie madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Marc F
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
député madame la députée vous faites une
parfaite démonstration au fond de de ce
qu'est la facilité parfois le populisme
c'est-à-dire la capacité à faire des
grandes phrases à faire des grandes
récriminations et à ne pas agir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et d'ailleurs ça va
me permettre de vous faire une
proposition parce que vous nous vous
nous demandez d'agir concrètement
concrètement il va y avoir un projet de
loi de fin de gestion dans lequel il y a
800 millions de crédits supplémentaires
qui sont alloués à l'agriculture pour
couvrir un certain nombre de crises dont
cell qu'on a tenu qu'on connait dans le
tarngaron j'espère que vous voterez au
moins ces crédits là parce que après il
faudra revenir devant les agriculteurs
pour all explor expliquer que sur la
grippe aviaère que sur un certain nombre
de dégâts qu'ils ont subis vous vous
vous les accompagnez pas deè premier
élément donc nous sommes au rendez-vous
800 millions d'euros en fin de gestion
pour couvrir les besoins donc on on
parle et on agit contrairement à vous me
semble-t-il deuxième élément vous l'avez
pas dit sans doute sans doute c'est
parce que les choses ont été fait en bon
ordre il y a une grave tempête cette
année dans le tern Garon on s'est réuni
avec les professionnels on a fait en
sorte d'essayer de couvrir les besoins
sur les pertes de fonds en revalorisant
les Barets et envalorisant le taux de
couverture sur un fond d'urgence que je
suis prêt à mettre sur la table je l'ai
dit d'ailleurs et les collectivités
locales vont nous accompagné pour faire
en sorte que les arborculaires qui sont
puissamment touchés puissent retrouver
la voie au fond de l'optimisme aussi
d'un chemin économique 3ème élément
c'est la question de la planification et
des grandes transitions vous êtes dans
un territoire ça c'est vrai qui subit de
plein fouet un impact important qui est
celui du dérèglement climatique avec un
certain nombre d'impass techniqu donc
plutôt que de les de conforter un
certain nombre d'agriculteurs dans le
statu qu vous devriez avec nous dans les
moyens qui sont mis compris dans le
budget agricole en terme de transition
c'est près d'un milliard d'euros faire
en sorte qu'on les accompagne dans les
transitions pour faire en sorte qu'il
puissent avoir accès à l'eau dans de
meilleures conditions pour faire en
sorte qu'il puissent faire évoluer leurs
assolement pour faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent investir c'est comme ça qu'on
accompagnera l'agriculture pas
simplement en essayant de conforter un
modèle dont on sait qu'il est en
difficulté et dont on sait qu'il faut
l'accompagner en tout cas nous on est au
rendez-vous pour le faire merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre madame monieur
ministre vous me parlez de mesures
ponctuelles je vous parle de réforme
structur je vous parle d'un plan
d'urgence les agriculteurs ne cherchent
pas l'omô ils cherchent à vivre
dignement de leur
travail je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Philippe Nilor pour le groupe la
France
insoumise monsieur le ministre des
outres dans le cadre du posi le régime
spécifique d'approvisionnement du RSA
vise à faciliter l'approvisionnement en
produits essentiel à la consommation
humaine ou à la produ AG et
agroindustriel dans nos territoires dit
d'outrem unanimement les filières
concernées de tous nos territoires n'ont
eu de cesse d'alerter l'État sur
l'insuffisante dotation de cette
enveloppe dont le plafond est bloqué à
27 millions depuis 2013 laissant
apparaître un manque global flagrant de
8 millions d'euros cependant en dépit
des engagement réitéré la main sur le
cœur par votre gouvernement à réévaluer
cette dotation dans le le cadre d'une
aide d'État les actes se font
cruellement attendre alors qu'il y a
urgence et que Bruxelles n'attend que
votre
notification dans un contexte
structurellement marqué par la vie chère
par des taux de chômage endémique par
l'inflation galopante et par la
domination impériale des importations
sur nos productions vos
tergiversations sur ce dossier ont
pourit fait d'aggraver les fléau en
générant une augmentation des prix des
productions locales leur perte de
compétitivité et la mise en péril des
emplois directs et indirects de ces
filières ce qui nous écarte vous
conviendrait chaque jour un peu plus des
objectifs de souveraineté de sécurité
alimentaire pourtant omniprésent dans
vos discours j'affirme que nos pays
n'ont pas vocation à demeurer
sitnellement des terres de consommation
de produits finis importés au détriment
de toute production locale monsieur le
ministre ministre ma question est claire
et précise elle attend de votre part une
réponse claire et précise êtes-vous prêt
enfin à répondre favorablement à cette
demande légitime d'abondement du RSA de
8 millions d'euros il en va de la survie
de nos productions
local merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe viget
ministre en charge des
outremires madame la Présidente madames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Philippe Nilor je connais votre
engagement pour l'agriculture on a eu ce
débat en commission des lois l'autre
jour et je vais vous répondre sans
détour vous savez très bien d'abord que
ce gouvernement aide l'agriculture je
rappelle qu'il y a pour les outremèes ce
qu'on appelle le posi qui est prolongé
comme vous le savez au même niveau que
l'année dernière à 280 million d'euros
et en 2024 il y a une aide qui vient de
la France et qui augmente de 33 % elle
passe de 45 à 60 millions d'euros dans
ces POS il y a deux jambes la première
c'est celle qui permet d'aider les
exploitations agricoles vous le savez et
il y a une deuxième et ce deuxième jambe
c'est quoi c'est ce fameux RSA qui est
bloqué vous avez raison vous l'avez dit
dans votre question qui est bloqué
depuis 2013 et il sert à faire quoi il
il sert à amortir les surcûts d à
l'importation d'un Tran qui servent à
quoi à produire notamment des aliments
pour les animaux donc on peut pas d'un
côté dire qu'il y aura plus de
souveraineté alimentaire et je me tourne
vers le ministre de l'Agriculture et de
l'autre ne pas se donner les moyens donc
il faut une démarche partagée parce que
les calculs nous disent qu'à l'heure
actuelle il faudrait 7 à 8 millions de
plus d'ici 2030 de manière à apporter
une réponse qui permett plus de
souveraineté alimentaire et qui permett
donc de vous donner satisfaction d'ors
et déjà les collectivités comme la
Région Guyane a donné son accord pour
cofinancer le département de La Réunion
a donné son accord j'imagine que vous
serez un ambassadeur pour la martidique
l'octroi de mer nous aidera et je suis
persuadé qu'avec le ministre
d'agriculture comme il vient de le dire
à l'instant dans une réponse à un autre
député on trouvera les vois et moyens en
tout cas je ferai tout avec vous pour
faire en sorte que enfin on dégèle cette
somme qui est bloquée depuis 2013 c'est
injuste ensemble nous trouverons la
solution merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Ellie califer pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente le
réchaffement climatique est désormais
une réalité en à peine de semaines la
Guadeloupe a subi avec efffoi le passage
dévastateur d'une tempête et d'un
oouagan permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée
pour les sinistrés et d'exprimer ma
reconnaissance à l'égard des services de
secours des collectivités
territoriale ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des autremèes et porte à la fois sur
l'urgence et sur l'avenir l'urgence
commande bien sûr de prendre l'arrêté
reconnaissant l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
plus de 2 semaines après votre
engagement monsieur le ministre il se
fait encore
attendre le temps est venu pour le
gouvernement de répondre à des
problématiques prignantes qui se posent
après chaque événement de climatique
majeur vous le savez en Guadeloupe seul
quelques assureurs acceptent d'assurer
les biens et les entreprises alors que
l'offre est plurielle dans l'exxagone
comment comptez-vous mettre en œuvre les
préconisations du rapport de l'IGF de
2000 20 concernant la problématique
assurancielle ultramarine sans faire
exploser les coûts pour nos
concitoyens concernant l'accompagnement
des collectivités après le nombre de
rencontres dans ma circonscription il
est nécessaire d'agir sur plusieurs
points d'abord clarifier l'architecture
des compétences en matière
d'intervention en faveur d' entretien
des couroups d'eau puis revoir les
procédures d'autorisation de travaux de
cuirage des ravines et des rivières des
dizaines d'ouvrages de franchissement
sont à reconstruire à fort à Vieux
Habitants à capester par exemple
monsieur le ministre es-vous prêt à
créer un fond spécial d'aménagement
résilient pour nos
territoire je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Vigier ministre en charge des
outremèes merci madame la présidente
madame messieur les députés monsieur le
député
califer depuis le début de cette séance
on parle malheureusement beaucoup de ces
uragans terribles on n pas eu de siarant
et et des décès qu'il avait eu j' était
venu vous le savez en Guadeloupe à la
Désirade suite au passage de Tami
heureusement on n'ait pas eu de de
victime à déplorer vous savez également
que les mobilisations des services de
l'État étent total les pompiers les
gendarmes bref tout le monde je crois
avec les communes avec les départements
les régions se sont mobilisés après il
nous faut tirer les leçons de tout cela
tirer les leçons de tout cela ça passe
par la résilience il faut comme l'ont
dit lorsqu'on a chaque fois une nouvelle
crise tiré ses expériences de manière à
mieux les appréhender je crois on l'a
fait pour Sian la première ministre le
disait ça a permis d'éviter vraiment
plus de décès alors que
cette cette tempête était absolument
terrible après nous avons des outils ces
outils vous les connaissez puisque vous
me demandez un fond je rappelle que sur
le contrôle de Christophe Béchu il y a
ce qu'on appelle les fonds verts qui
peuvent être mobilisés par les
collectivités qui ont été fortément
mobilisés en 2023 et qu'ils seront tout
autant en 2024 je rappelle qu'il y a les
fonds barniers les fonds barniers ont
été fait pour cela et justement ces
fonds il faut là encore massivement les
mobiliser parce que ils sont
parfaitement adaptés aussi de situation
que vous évoquez je voudrais vous dire
aussi que il y a eu le plan séis
mantillle et ce plan sis mantillle il
est à disposition des collectivités
encore là pour les conforter oui il faut
tirer des leçons naturellement sur les
constructions oui il faut tirer des
leçons sur ce comment on doit
appréhender ces niveau séismes les uns
après les autres ces ouragans toujours
plus violents donc ces fonds existent
nous les mobilisons et vous savez très
bien que le gouvernement notamment par
le dispositif catastrophe naturelle qui
a été évoqué ici même il y a quelques
semaines sera effective en particulier
pour la Désirade là où il méritait de
l'être
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député merci à vous
je vous demandé des actions concrètes et
surtout eu m' eff fait un cours de
communication sauf queil faudra par
rapport au retrait de côte aménager
autrement les territoires et le fond
Barnier ne suffira pas il est déjà assez
faible merci à vous monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
pour le groupe horizon merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Sabrina gresti Rouach
secrétaire d'État chargé de la ville et
de la citoyenneté le sport permet à
chacun de se réaliser dans l'effort et
de s'émanciper quel que soit son origine
sa culture et sa condition sociale à
moins d'un an des Jeux olympiques de
Paris mais ai-je le besoin de rappeler
le caractère universel des valeurs du
sport mais aussi le nécessaire respect
dans le sport des valeurs républicaines
or je regrette que celle-ci soit
malheureusement de plus en plus
contestée comme c'est le cas en ce
moment par des clubs de franciliia de
basketball près de 70 7 clubs de basket
de la région Île-de-France contestent en
effet le règlement de leur fédération
nationale en souhaitant autoriser le
Couvrechef sportif c'est-à-dire dans les
fait un voile islamique pour les
compétitions féminines dans cette
discipline j'ai été alerté par la
présidente Valérie pcrz de la région et
son vice-président chargé des sports
Patrick Caram qui depuis 2017 mène un
combat ferme sur le respect de la
laïcité à travers le déploiement d'une
charte régionale des valeurs de la
République dont l'état peut-être
d'ailleurs pourrait s'inspirer pourtant
la fédération de basket est une des
rares fédérations qui en France a pris
ses responsabilité en édictant des
règles claires qui prohibent les signes
ostentatoires d'appartenance religieuse
pendant les compétitions sportives le
Conseil d'État par une décision du 29
juin dernier a rappelé que c'est aux
fédérations sportives qu'il revient de
faire appliquer le principe de
neutralité du service public or sur le
terrain trop peu de fédérations de trois
seulement ont rappelé l'exigence de
neutralité c'est donc aux acteurs de
terrain arbitre entraîneur éducateur
président de club qu'il revient le plus
souvent au quotidien de faire face à des
atteintes aux règles de la République je
sais combien le gouvernement est attaché
à un régime de laïcité stricte appliqué
aussi dans le champ du sport on l'a vu
avec l'annonce pris de qui interdit pour
les membres de la des délégations
françaises de porter le voile pendant
les prochains jeux olympiques aussi j'ai
deux questions comment comptez-vous
obtenir des fédérations que rapidement
elles édictent des règles claires et
précises pour garantir la laïcité dans
le discipline mais au-delà ne serait-il
pas plus opportun de définir un cadre
légal national sur le port de signe
religieux qui s'appliquerait à
l'ensemble des compétitions merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Agresti
roubach ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Frédéric
Valtou vous cherchez ù la République est
régulièrement la cible d'organisation
vous avez raison politico-religieuse qui
teste la résistance de nos principes
républicains pour cette raison dès
2021 nous nous sommes dotés de nombreux
outils pour l'adoption de la loi
confortant le respect des principes de
la République face à ces attaques comme
vous l'avez rappelé comme l'a rappelé
aussi la ministre des sport la la
réponse du gouvernement est claire
fermeté lucidité vigilance sur les 3500
contrôles de club sportif cette année 27
ont effectivement donné lieu à des
signaux faibles de séparatisme pour y
faire pass nous avons arrêté le plan
d'action dont je ne citerai que les
principales mesures déploiement d'un
réseau de 117 référents pour la
prévention de la radicalisation
mobilisation de référence citoyenneté
dans les fédérations programmation de
6000 contrôles dans les clubs sportif la
récente décision du Conseil d'État vient
consolider l'application du principe de
laïcité dans le sport elle appelle aussi
à une analyse au cas par cas avec des
restrictions nécessaires et
proportionnées j'ai confiance en nos
fédérations elles seront en mesure de
déterminer les règles nécessaires pour
faire primer les principes de la
République sous le contrôle du ministère
des sport et avec l'appuie du ministère
de l'Intérieur et des outres mèes nous
serons à leur côté pour les accompagner
mesdames et messieurs les députés soyons
clair la main du gouvernement ne
tremblera pas face aux attaques de notre
pacte républicain je vous remercie
député merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier serv pour leoupe
ot merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre des outres maires délégués
chers collègues il y a quelques semaines
saidïda étudiante guadeloupéenne en
région lyonnaise m'a transféré un mail
qui cher collègue m'a
scandalisé sur ce mail il est indiqué
par une agence immobilière du groupe
Foncia je cite les conditions de la
garantie loyer payé ne permettent pas de
présenter un garant qui ne réside pas en
France métropolitaine
avez-vous un autre garant à présenter
sinon nous ne pourrons pas vous
attribuer l'appartement fin de citation
une question me préoccupe monsieur le
ministre pèse-t-il sur les parents
ultramarins une présomption DESS
solvabilités une présomption
desincapacité à subvenir aux besoins de
leurs enfants en étude expliquez-moi
comment une personne qui se trouve aux
abîmes à papè ou encore à sain Laurent
du Maroni procède-t-elle pour trouver un
garant à plus de 8000 km sur un
territoire où le plus souvent il ne
connaît personne ou au mieux une poignée
de proche et lorsque ce proche existe il
doit accepter de se porter garant et
n'est pas forcément solvable ce qui
n'est pas une garantie facile monsieur
le ministre vous l'aurez compris
l'installation d'étudiant ultramarin en
poursuite d'étude en hexagone relève du
parcours du combattant pourtant
l'article
l221 de la loi du 6 juillet 89 interdit
au bailleurs de refuser une caution
bancaire au motif qu'elle n'est pas
domiciliée dans l'Hexagone cette
discrimination tombe sur le coup des
articles 225 1 et 2252 du code pénal et
est passible de 45000 € d'amende et de 3
ans d'emprisonnement par conséquent
monsieur le ministre nous voulons une
application stricte de la loi par les
assurances et bailleurs nous pas des
bâards nous ne sommes pas des bâtards de
la République quelles sont donc les
actions de contrôle que votre
gouvernement compte mettre en place pour
faire appliquer cette loi et faire
cesser cette discrimination je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Biget ministre en
charge des outres
Mair merci madame la présidente madame
messieur les députés monsieur le député
Olivier serva en découvrant l'histoire
de cette jeune femme simplement je vais
vous dire les mots ils sont simples
c'est intolérable inacceptable c'est une
faute qui a été commise par cette
fameuse agence parce qu'elle avait une
caution familiale ses parents sont
ultraarins elle aurait dû bénéficier
comme un hexagonal de la possib d'
logement il y a aucune excuse à donner à
une telle démarche et croyez bien que
nous sommes vigilants mais votre
question permet de dire est-ce que vous
non nous faisons plus d'efforts pour les
ultramarins et les étudiants en
particulier vous savez qu'ils sont 86000
et pour lesquels il y a des niveaux
dispositifs qui sont en place les
bourses augmentent significativement
d'ailleurs plus que celle pour les
hoxagonaux elles augmentent grâce à
l'intervention de de Sylvie rutillot ma
collègue de manière à ce qu'on soit plus
déclencheur deuxièmement pour la
continuité territoriale ce qui permet
aux étudiants vous le savez de rentrer
de l'Hexagone vers leur famille et
d'ailleurs cette disposition nouvelle
s'appliquera dès les vacances de Noël
que les étudiants soient boursiers ou
non boursiers 100% du billet sera pris
en charge desès Noël c'est un effort
significatif on augmente ses crédits de
35 %. pour les fameuses cautions pour
les fameuse caution dont vous parlez je
rappelle qu'il y a une caution viséale
qui permet d'échapper justement à la
caution parentale et c'est l'État qui
apporte cette caution voilà quelque
chose de nouveau qui nous permet
d'éviter ce drame que nous avons vécu
avec cette jeune étudiante donc voyez
que partout pour et élargir la palette
de formation pour proposer une meilleure
mobilité pour mieux garantir l'accè au
logement le gouvernement est là pour
répondre à l'attente que vous avez
formulé je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
Christine descot pour le groupe
Renaissance madame la Présidente chè
collègues madame la ministre de la
Citoyenneté de la ville 5,4 millions
habitant soit 8 % de la population
française résideent dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
le comité interministérial des villes du
27 octobre dernier à chanteloup- les
vignes veut marquer une nouvelle étape
dans l'histoire de la politique de la
ville avec le lancement d'une nouvelle
génération dénommée engagement quartier
2030 ces futurs contrats de ville par
leur changement de méthode
simplification et accélération de
l'action publique ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives favorisant notamment
l'accès à tous les services publics le
plein emploi la transition écologique
dans ces quartiers où il fait trop chaud
l'été et trop froid l'hiver où la
sobriété énergétique est plus souvent
subie que choisie dans ces quartiers où
encore trop souvent l'angoisse des
charges des futures factures de
chauffage vient amputer un moral déjà
mis à mal par les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne pouvez-vous nous indiquer
madame la ministre les mesures en terme
d'écologie du quotidien que vous allez
por pour les habitants au côté des
collectivités et quelles sont vos
priorités pour la période 2024-2030
merci merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Sabrina gr Rouach ministre en
charge de la ville et de la citoyenne
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée Christine descotte vous
m'interrogez sur les mesures en matière
d'écologie du quotidien pour les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville et je
vous en remercie je l'avais dit je
voulais plus de bleu mais aussi beaucoup
plus de verre cette question a longtemps
été quantonnée à un seul sujet
concernant les quartiers et j'en sais
quelque chose celui de la rénovation et
énergétique des logements si cette
dimension est évidemment importante il
est toutefois indispensable selon moi
d'avoir une vision plus
ambitieuse et c'est ce que porte le
gouvernement sous l'autorité de la
première ministre le comité
interministériel des villes du 27
octobre a proposé sur ce sujet des
mesures fortes il s'agit notamment du
doublement de la part du fond vert
investi dans les quartiers du
déploiement d'air éducative qui en plus
d'ajouter des espaces verts permettront
de sensibiliser mieux les jeunes aux
enjeux de la biodiversité 24 nouveaux
quartiers résilients ont par ailleurs
été annoncés le gouvernement veut
également permettre le déploiement des
mobilités douces et durable en
expérimentant le recours automatique à
la tarification sociale solidaire en
matière de transport en commun vous
l'aurez compris madame la députée ces
actions spécifiques jouent sur
l'ensemble des leviers possibles pour
pour rendre nos quartiers plus verts
enfin lorsque l'on met plus d'humain
plus d'opportunités plus de lien on
permet une une meilleure prise en compte
des enjeux de l'écologie du quotidien
par les habitants eux-mêmes et pas
uniquement par les autres c'est ce que
nous ferons avec la généralisation par
exemple des cités éducatives la mixité
sociale dans l'attribution de logements
sociaux ou encore le renforcement de
l'accès aux soins et encore bien
d'autres priorités et on aura le temps
d'en parler vous m'aviez déjà questionné
la dernière fois on prendra un
rendez-vous pour que vous détaille tout
parfaitement merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup madame la ministre madame la
députée madame la ministre j'accueille
bien évidemment avec intérêt ces mesures
je réponds d'ailleurs favorablement à
votre invitation et je compte bien
évidemment sur les services de l'État
pour déployer avec les acteurs locaux
les mesures prises auprès des
territoires concernés et de leurs
habitants merci merci
beaucoup la parole est à
Madame
national merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Gérard armanin ministre de
l'intérieur alors que chaque jour nos
territoires rurux luttent contre les
départs des médecins contre la fermeture
des commerce de proximité des écoles des
services publics les voilà maintenant
frappés de plein fouet par l'explosion
de l'insécurité du trafic de drogue si
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau il
s'amplifie d'année en année
oisonnant la vie des temps la charante
où je suis élue et ces communes rurales
qui étaient jadis de paisible bourgade
sont devenus le théâtre de règlement de
compte d'agression ultravolente
d'enlèvement de menaces et de pression
sur les riverins plus inquiétant encore
le nombre de consommateurs explosent et
les jeunes sont des cibles faciles pour
ces nouveaux cartels de la drogue qui
sévisent dans ces campagnes rongé par la
précarité galopante et l'effondrement du
pouvoir d'achat que nous dénonçons
chaque jour avec Marie Le Pen et le
rassemblement national
les saisies sont de plus en plus
régulières les enquêteurs sont débordés
et on parle de plusieurs dizaines de
tonnes saisies l'occasion pour nous de
féliciter le travail des forces de
gendarmerie et de police notamment du
groupe de recherche antidrogue qui font
un travail remarquable cependant cela
n'est pas assez je suis désolé monsieur
le ministre ce ne sont pas les nouvelles
brigades j'allais dire du tigre de
gendarmerie annoncé par le président de
la République qui suffiront à éradiquer
ce fléo vous n'avez rien fait contre la
drogue des villes quen serait-il de la
drogue des champs la passivité du
gouvernement et du pain béni pour les
dealers qui arrose désormais les
campagnes de cocaïne d'héroïne et de
cannabis monsieur le ministre maintenant
que la drogue est dans le prê que
comptez-vous faire pour lutter contre ce
fléo qui gangrainene nos campagne je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Sabrina Agresti roubach
ministre de la Citoyenneté et de la
ville merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée colombien vous m'interrogez
donc sur l'amplification et vous avez
raison du trafic de stupéfiants dans les
communes rurales vous le savez la lutte
contre les les trafics de stupéfiants
est une priorité du gouvernement ne vous
en déplaise aucune différence n'est
faite entre les territoirees urbains et
ruraux dans notre action déterminée pour
combattre ce fléo partout où il se
développe concrètement l'action des
forces de l'ordre se fonde sur un plan
national de lutte contre les stupéfiants
pilotés par l'ofaste depuis depuis 2019
la gendarmerie y est pleinement associée
vous le savez et est compétente dans les
zones rurales et périis urbaines pour
l'année 2022 les résultats enregistrés
par la gendarmerie sont très positifs si
même si nous aspirons à frapper toujours
plus fort et je pense qu'on fera jamais
assez contre le trafic de drogue 15,5
tonnes de résine ou d'Herb de cannabis
ont été saisies en 2022 soit le double
par rapport à
2021 on en parlera plus tard de
Marseille vous me poserez une question
je peux aussi reprendre l'exemple du
travail formidable que les forces de
l'ordre ont accompli récemment dans
votre département en charante vous le
savez oui madame la députée les trafics
de stupéfiant s'insinue également dans
nos campagnes nous avons le devoir
ensemble de les combattre sans relâche
lutter contre ce fléo reste et demeure
pour nous une priorité police et
gendarmerie mobilise quotidiennement et
se mobilise quotidiennement pour la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue et si
vous le permettez je dis aussi il manque
mot dans votre question la prévention la
prévention contre les les conduites
addictives qui touchent les quartiers
prioritaires et les campagnes et je
pense qu'on doit amplifier sur la
prévention et c'est la priorité de du
ministère de la Citoyenneté sous
l'autorité du ministre de l'Intérieur je
vous
remercie merci
beaucoup allez-y madame la députée
j'ajouterai juste que je pense qu'il ne
faut pas attendre d'en faire des zones
de non droit ou des zones de non France
car ça les Français ne l'accepteront pas
et particul
dans la
ruralité je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sarah
Legrain pour le groupe la France
insoumise monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 7 janvier
dernier Lucas 13 ans mettait fin à ses
jours nous nous demanderons toujours ce
drame aurait-il pu être évité combien de
souffrance de violence homophobe sexist
sexuel qui frappe quotidiennement des
jeunes pourrait être évité j'ai lu votre
plan harcèlement j'y vois d'énigmatique
cours d'empathie mais pas une ligne sur
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle dans votre budget non plus pas
une ligne impossible de discuter les
moyens affectés pour cause de 493 or les
rapports officiels les chefs
d'établissement infirmières scolair
représentant de parents et d'élèves
alertent la loi de 2001 n'est pas
respectée seul 15 à 20 % des élèves
reçoivent les trois séances obligatoire
par an hier au Sénat un collectif inédit
composé d'une dizaine d'organisations et
de fédérations présentaiit son livre
blanc pour une véritable éducation à la
sexualité avec des contenus harmonisés
adaptés à chaque âge associant les
parents monsieur le ministre vous
n'étiez pas là 2 jours plus tôt le Sénat
accueillait le collocque des parents
vigilants cette officine zmouristes qui
sous le slogan protégeons nos enfants
répand des fake news et cible l'école
républicaine monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez rien dit l'éducation à la vie
affective et sexuelle protège nos
enfants elle les protège des violences
et des cyber violences en hausse en
parlant droit à in imité respect du
consentement réciprocité égalité valeurs
qui ne règnent pas toujours dans leur
environnement ou sur leurs écrans elle
les protège des grossesses non désiré
mais aussi des infections sexuellement
transmissibles sur lesquelles
l'information a régressé comme
enseignante j'en ai vu des jeunes gens
libérés de leurs interrogations de leurs
complexes de leurs préjugés grâce à des
espaces de dialogue créé par les
associations sur un terrain où parents
et professeurs se sent souvent démunis
oui l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle protège or elle est menacée par
votre action politique par les
agissements de l'extrême droite monsieur
le ministre de quoi avez-vous peur
comptez-vous faire respecter la loi et
que ferez-vous de ces 46
recommandations je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier
Verand à Monsieur Gabriel Atal ministre
de l'Éducation et de la jeunesse merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Sarah legin quand près d'un garçon sur
trois déclare dans une récente enquête
penser qu'une femme peut aimer être
forcée à une relation sexuelle on voit
qu'il y a un problème et quand dans une
enquête on voit que plus de 40 % des
garçons déclarent s'informer sur le sexe
via des contenus pornographiques sur
Internet on voit qu'il y a un problème
c'est un problème de société qui dépasse
très largement l'éducation nationale on
y travaille avec Charlotte cobel avec
Jean-Noël barreau avec beréranger
Couillard et d'autres mais c'est un
problème auquel l'éducation nationale
doit contribuer à répondre et moi je le
dis madame la députée je pense que ce
sujetl doit être dépassionné
politiquement je crois pas que vous
servez la cause en politisant ce sujet
je pense je pense qu'il faut de la
transparence je pense qu'il faut de la
transparence en direction des familles
je pense qu'il faut de la concertation
et je pense qu'il faut de la méthode
laissez-moi aller au bout de ma réponse
je pense qu'il faut de la méthode et la
méthode elle est très claire non non
madame
lein vous reposez ça s'il vous plaît
vous écoutez le ministre auquel vous
venez de poser une question la méthode
elle est très
claire monsieur le ministre la méthode
elle est très claire nous avons un
conseil supérieur des programmes qui est
chargé de l'élaboration des programmes
qui a été missionné en juin dernier
avant même mon arrivée avant mon arrivée
au ministère de l'Éducation nationale
qui a été missionné pour faire des
propositions et des recommandations sur
les programmes en la matière le Conseil
supérieur des programmes doit remettre
des propositions d'ici à la fin de
l'année au mois de décembre évidemment
que pour élaborer ces recommandations il
échange avec l'ensemble des acteurs et
compris associatifs et que le livre
blanc que vous avez évoqué qui a été
présenté au Sénat fera évidemment partie
des travaux qui sont menés aujourd'hui
par le Conseil supérieur des programmes
et à la lumière des recommandations du
Conseil supérieur des programmes qui
sont importantes nous aurons l'occasion
de prendre les décisions les plus
adaptées merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Vigier pour le groupe les
républicain merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires trop peu trop tard et
trop compliqué voilà comment le Comité
des finances locales qualifie le filet
de sécurité mis en place pour aider les
communes à faire face à la crise
inflationniste et et pour cause cet
outil est apparu comme une véritable
usine à gaz excluant de nombreuses
collectivités confronté à la flambée des
prix de l'énergie l'arrêté fixant le
montant définitif du filet de sécurité
ne fait qu'aggraver ce triste résultat
en effet et vous le savez monsieur le
ministre en lieu et place des 22000
communes qui devaient toucher une
dotation moins de 3000 moins de 3000
sont finalement concernés c'est h fois
moins que le nombre initial prévu par le
gouvernement
pire beaucoup d'entre elles devront voir
rembourser tout ou partie de la compte
qu'elles avaient reçu au titre de ce
dispositif cette nouvelle desconvenu
entérine l'échec du filet de sécurité
elle acte le mépris adressé aux élus
locaux qui n'ont jamais démérité pour
faire face aux fortes tensions
budgétaires loin d'améliorer les
conditions économiques des communes cet
arrêté va enfoncer de nombreux m dans
l'inquiétude nous devons en finir avec
ces méthodes mesquines bah oui qui pr
les Mair de le pouvoir d'agir et leur
capacité
d'initiative alors Monsieur le Ministre
allez-vous réellement exiger ces
remboursements au risque d'accentuer la
précarité financière de nos
collectivités territorial je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Vigier je
sais votre attachement collectivité
territoriale et je reconnais dans votre
voix dans vos propos la constance de ce
combat mais disons les choses
concrètement ce filet de sécurité
l'article 14 de la loi de finance
rectificative du 16 août 22 quel les
critères ont été fixés dans cet
hémicycle à la fois le montant et les
trois conditions cumulatives avoir une
épargne brute qui soit qui soit qui soit
inférieure à 22 % un potentiel fiscal
inférieur à deux fois la moitié et une
baisse de l'épargne brune qui devait
être inférieur à 25 % c'est critères
qu'auriez-vous dit si nous les avions
pas appliqué le gouvernement quand il se
retrouve
avec je ne peux pas croire un diè de
seconde que vous expliquiez que vous
considérez qu'on doit pas appliquer la
loi la loi il disait il y a trois
critères l'application de ces critères
elle a conduit sur la base des comptes
administratifs qui étaient donc
disponible fin juin à constater que nous
avions 3000 communes pour 405 millions
d'euros sur les 450 qui étaient
concernés la conséquence que nous en
avons ti ici également en décembre
dernier c'est un filet de sécurité qui
n'est pas de 450 millions mais de
1illard 500 millions d'euros pour
l'année 2023 avec non plus trois
critères de porte d'entrée mais un seul
en revanche ce que la loi a décidé en
août 22 le gouvernement l'applique
évidemment sur la base du vote du
Parlement donc nous avons décembre
dernier amélioré le dispositif pour
l'année en cours mais vous ne pouvez pas
nous demander de manière rétroactive de
réécrire les critères tels qu'ils
avaient été décidés
collectivement merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre monsieur le député c'est
très simple monsieur le ministre
corriger ces critères nos communes en
non besoin elles font un travail
exemplaire et aujourd'hui elles sont
fragiles et elles sont pénalisées
corrigez ces critères aidez nos communes
je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur député nous avons
collectivementé critère pour l'année en
cours et je me permets de vous dire que
la somme que nous avions accordé
collectivement qui était de 450 millions
elle est quasiment celle qui a été
attribuée par le décret du 13 octobre
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame mélodie Jacquier
Laforge pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur Marc fen monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues si je vous dis
parisienne franquette Maillette fer Nord
Lara à quoi pensez-vous à la noix à la
noix de Grenoble c'est pas une chanteuse
mon cher collègue la culture de la noix
la nuciculture n'est pas épargnée elle
non plus par le changement climatique la
sécheresse les tempêtes la grêle et
depuis quelques années elle accumule
toutes les difficultés en 2022 la
récolte a été certes exceptionnelle avec
une production de 30 à 40 % en plus
supérieur à la normale du jamais vu mais
cette production remarquable en France
mais aussi dans les autres pays
producteurs de noix c'est
malheureusement accompagné d'une baisse
massive un effondrement même de la
consommation mondiale de ce fruit à coq
les prix vous l'imaginez se sont donc
écroulés en 2023 nouveau coup dur une
récolte exceptionnellement basse plonge
les n ulteur dans d'autres difficultés à
venir vous le savez la op de la noix de
Grenoble s'est organisée desès 1993 pour
réfléchir et développer des moyens de
production respectueux plus efficaces et
plus neutre en terme d'atteinte à
l'environnement c'est ainsi qu' a été
créé la cénura la station
d'expérimentation nuicol ronalp cette
station de recherche innovante que vous
connaissez bien pour l'instant l'absence
aujourd'hui de itable structure de la
filière à la fois en iser mais aussi en
France expose à une particulière
fragilité nos producteur de noix c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais connaître les mesures que
vous souhaitez mettre en place pour
accompagner cette filière je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Marc F ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la Présidente ja lafor
merci de votre question d'AB pour
rappeler ce qui la filière noix en
France c'est le deè verger derrière les
pommes 25000 hactares 25 à 30 % en
agriculture biologique la France est le
2e exportateur mondial de noix à coque
derrière les États-Unis le 4e
exportateur mondial pour les cernau et
les noix malgré ces éléments qui devrait
nous inviter plutôt à l'optimisme la
filière noix traverse une crise comme
d'autres ça a été évoqué par d'autres
députés sur d'autres secteurs une une
crise conjoncturelle mais aussi une
crise structurel donc il nous faut
répondre d'abord à la crise du moment
qui est liée à des aléas climatiques ont
fait trop de production ou pas assez des
aléas inflationnistes si je peux dire
qu'il faut qu'il y a des baisses de
consommation j'ajoute que la production
de noix au niveau la consommation de
noix au niveau mondial est plutôt sur
une tendance croissante hors les années
2023 et peut-être 2024 et donc on a
besoin de répondre à la crise on a
répondu on répond à la crise au travers
de dispositifs de la réserve de crise
européenne dans laquelle l'Europe va
apporter des moyens c'est 10 millions
d'euros pour la cerise et pour la noix 8
millions de l'Europe de crédits
européens et 2 millions de crédits
nationaux en compléments qui per
permettront d'appuyer les nuciculteurs
et de faire en sorte que près de 80 % de
la perte par rapport à un résultat
classique puisse prise être prise en
charge dans le cadre de ce dispositif le
guichet est ouvert nous avons fait en
sorte que le plus grand nombre de
nucicuteur puisse en bénéficier puis
deuxième élément il faut qu'on travaille
sur le moyen et long terme répondre à la
crise immédiate et répondre à la crise
structurelle vous avez raison on a
besoin de mieux organiser la filière
d'abord pour avoir une production qui
réponde à la demande on produit beaucoup
de fruits à coque évidemment par nature
mais il faut qu'on arrive à exporter
plutôt des cernau parce que c'est plutôt
ça le marché qui est une tendance donc
il faut qu'on arrive à transformer mieux
la noix premier élément deuxième élément
il faut inciter les producteurs à
s'organiser il y a un certain nombre
d'initiatives qui ont êté prises par
exemple dans votre département mais
globalement il faut que les producteurs
s'organisent ça leur permettra d'accéder
à un certain nombre de fonds qui
permettront de moderniser des outils de
production de faire aussi de la
valorisation de la noix nous sommes un
pays qui produit beaucoup de noix mais
qui consomme à l'habitant assez peu de
noix et donc on a besoin aussi de faire
des campagnes de communication donc on
répond à la crise de court terme et au
besoins de long terme merci Madame merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la séance
des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est
suspendue